ladies and gentlemen it is a wild week
the Republican party in Colorado says
that if they remove Trump from the
ballot as it appears they have they will
not even have a primary they're
threatening to withdraw from the primary
system and convert to a caucus system
and they're telling VI ramaswami you you
need not pull out because we're going to
convert to a caucus so this would
basically nullify
what this ruling says but that's not
completely true the ruling would also
bar Trump from the general election as
well so if they convert from a primary
to a caucus sure Trump can still win the
caucus system and then maybe become the
nominee but doesn't mean he can be in
the general election in Colorado which
means I believe about 1.5 to 1.8 million
Republican votes removed from the
popular vote count we have a lot to
discuss as it pertains to this now of
course VI Ras Swami said he would drop
out he called on Ron Christie Nikki
Haley do the same Ronda santz has come
out boldly saying no way he will not
drop out because he doesn't think it's
legitimate anyway he thinks the ruling
will be overturned and and he he calls
us I gotta be H very confusingly says it
would play into the hands of the left to
stand with Donald Trump and drop out of
the race which literally makes no sense
but sure we'll talk about that a bunch
of other news surrounding this and of
course everyone's two favorite words as
uh we're getting into this subject but
I'm not going to give you your
satisfaction I'm going to say National
divorce this time anyway cuz now you
don't get to drink before we get started
my friends head over to the best song
ever.com click download at your price
you'll get 35% off your next casw
purchase for a mere 69 buying our latest
song together again can earn you 35% of
any coffee purchase at cpw.com I got to
tell you it's worth it so far it looks
like we may have sold between 12 and
15,000 songs which is really really
great I really do appreciate the support
from every single person um but those
are rookie numbers we got to get those
numbers up it's looking like now and
I'll give you an update on this because
uh this was us teaming up with the daily
wire basically we want to build culture
we want to be uh funny with it we want
to have a good time we want to make good
music and we want to tell Fu to the
music industry we're hearing now that a
portion of our numbers they're not
counting and they're telling us they
can't count and I knew something like
this was going to happen because Tom
McDonald's had the same problem he gets
a he put he puts a song out gets
millions of fits he should be on the Hot
100 every single time and they keep they
keep him off the list so now it does
look like Billboard's on our side who
knows they're saying something's wrong
the numbers aren't being counted
properly surprise surprise
so you know they're trying to steal it
from us they're trying to steal it from
us so uh we need to overwhelm it we over
so support our work download the song if
you really want to help song purchases
count as like 150 times listening to the
song so if you like the song or just
want to support the mission that we have
please consider downloading the song and
uh we'll see how it turns out in about I
think it's like a week and a half from
now we'll find out what where we stand
on Billboard head over to timcast.net
glad to be back who are you what are you
doing uh my name is Michael malice uh
you can watch my show you're welcome
this week I have Will Chamberlain and
Dave Smith discussing Israel next week
we have someone who I tried to get here
as a surprise to you you didn't even
know this last year on April fools Megan
McCain ah so she's gonna be on my show
next week recorded already but you came
it says she didn't come correct yeah um
so and my episode on Jordan Peterson's
podcast where I get him to uh to
convince him of the virtues of anarchism
drops tomorrow oh very nice wi W this
would be fun Hannah CL bmo's hanging out
hey I'm Hannah CL brimo I'm a writer for
cnr.com also known as scanner news I'm
excited to be here with you guys Ian's
here hello everyone I'm back took a nice
rest last night after our Turning Point
Excursion I was wiped of those four days
but it was great to see everybody at the
event really good to meet everybody good
to be a part of that so I'm glad to be
back hello what's happening Serge yeah
you were uh you kind of sold the show
the last little bit there that was great
I loved it it was good uh yeah hey
everyone um super super glad you're here
Michael it' be fun let's do this let's
roll from cnr.com Colorado Republican
party says they will withdraw from
primary and convert to caucuses if Trump
ruling STS quote a majority of the Court
holds that President Trump is
disqualified from holding the office of
president under section three of the
14th amend the United States
Constitution the ruling said because he
has disqualified it would be wrongful a
wrongful act under the election code for
the Colorado Secretary State to list him
as a candidate on the presidential
primary ballot the lawsuit was filed by
citizens for responsibility and ethics
in uh DC based Watchdog group this we
knowas Swami of course said that he
would with withdraw from the GOP Primary
until Trump is allowed to be on the
ballot in response to this the Colorado
Republican party says you won't have to
because we will withdraw from the
primary as a party and convert to a pure
caucus system if this is allowed to
stand it's getting pretty dang wild I
must say now as we mentioned uh uh in
the opening to the show that's great it
it still doesn't matter because Colorado
Supreme Court says Trump can't even run
in the general so if this is if if this
comes to January 4th maybe even sooner
Trump is going to appeal to the Supreme
Court I think there's a very very very
strong reason why the Supreme Court will
say no many reasons in fact those though
many many argue that the Supreme Court
will
intervene it it it is yet to be seen I I
think it I feel like they probably will
I mean this is way too serious I I think
it would I not only do I think they will
I think it would be 7 to1 or 8 to Zer
because the judicial branch since the
beginning has been very reticent about
getting involved when it comes to votes
and things like this they really like it
to be and Jefferson was like like
thought that the Congress should be able
to supersede what the Supreme Court has
to say they really don't like it when
judges strike things off ballots and
things like that or get involved so this
is the other thing that's very important
from a legal perspective is Trump hasn't
been convicted of insurrection he's not
this is something that he's been alleged
to have done he hasn't been demonstrated
or and deranged it's not so funny when
Trump calls him instead of calling him D
just calls him deranged Jack Smith chose
not to charge him with Insurrection so
for them to unilaterally basically
backdoor uh Insurrection guilty uh um
conviction to this is really a bridge
too far and when you start interfering
with presidential politics and you're
like one state this is something
Supremes really don't like doing CU this
is a big bridge to cross right the
Minnesota Supreme Court said no he
didn't commit Insurrection this has to
be decided by the party we we can't take
him off the ballot I is that what they
said that was Minnesota they that was
their official they said I'll pull it
right now but I thought their rolling
was we do not have we cannot supersede
the US Constitution as terms in in terms
of eligibility for they said they can't
rule on something a major political
party can can decide and they noted that
he hadn't been convicted so the thing is
like there are already Supreme Court
cases that say this doesn't work we have
immediate precedent and wasn't this 43
in Colorado if I'm not mistaken it yeah
well that was my thought that it's
immediately going to the US Supreme
to nothing unanimous be like this is
stupid why should it cuz this why should
it go to because it's such a big dealt
understand it's a big deal but
like I do think the Supreme Court would
intervene because it's a big deal but
I'll give you I'll play Devil's Advocate
sure if Starbucks decides to hold an
election to determine the the chairman
of the board should the Supreme Court
intervene if Starbucks changes the rules
as to how the election is that's a
private company and this is a private
organization the RNC yeah but it's not
private because when you have there's
all sorts of regulations and things
about who can get on the ballot who
cannot like they've been LW for example
like you know California is like a
jungle Primary in the general there's
all sorts of rules and regulations by
what parties because there's many states
for example where if I want to make it
that I'm the Republican Party only
registered Republicans can vote they
still made laws that basically if you're
independent you can vote the different
states different different laws then
Fair Point perhaps the Supreme Court
does intervene for that reason saying
the state has no authority to intervene
in a private organization electoral
either way yeah it works Robert Barnes
tweeted out which I thought was kind of
yeah this is probably from 5:00 p.m. 458
it so the easiest path for Scot is to
take in the Colorado Supreme Court Trump
disqualified case is to hold a court
hold is to hold a court has no
constitutional role in excluding a
presidential candidate from the ballot
in the first place that that is a choice
the Constitution gives to State
Legislature in Congress however this is
a private entity that is uh being
affected by this but but again it's it's
fair to say this is the state government
intervening in a private entity
it I think there's a strong argument
considering what we saw with Texas V
Pennsylvania in 2020 that is it 2020 to
2021 the Supreme Court simply says the
rules for private organizations fall to
the state to decide the federal
government has no grounds to intervene
in what a and how a state decides uh uh
nonprofit entities operate or public
good service entities operate but but my
thoughts also go to George Santos who
God bless him have you had him on by the
way no oh you got to get him on uh when
there are a lot of people in the house
and I think they had a fair point and I
certainly don't have a particular lot of
love for congress people when the
Congress people are like we can't kick
him out if he hasn't been convicted of
anything yet like this is really
crossing a line that do you really want
to go down this line where like we are
just picking choosing who are fellow
members are CU that ax is going to be
used against us at some point I agree I
agree but the question
is if a private entity within a state is
engaging in a practice the state says no
to can the feds intervene there are
certain circumstances I I agree however
I do think the Democrats are going to
start screaming nth and 10th Amendment
saying the federal government has no
right to tell a state they can't run
their own election as they see fit
there's no question that you're correct
because the Democrats will take any you
know opportunity like they'll be
tomorrow they pretend the 10 amend
doesn't exist you know of course they'll
use that but but that's the argument
they'll use and listen they're also
making the argument that preventing you
being able to vote from Trump is saving
democracy I I I love it I sort of see
this as an inevit ability and an
inoculation like the Supreme Court's
going to make a stand and say president
you cannot do it let's just set the
president and move on I I think it's an
inevitability because the regime isn't
going down without a fight and I've been
saying this for a long time everyone is
aware of this they're not just going to
one dat be like you know what we lost
good game guys they are going let's all
shake hands and go home their entire
their ENT right their entire two yeah
their entire ideology is you have to
tweak the rules until you get the
outcome that you want now in other cases
that might be actually a good thing if
we're all playing a game and somehow the
game always ends up with Ian winning
even though we're playing fairly maybe
the rules are kind of skewed for people
with hair length I don't know you know
be really funny what I think you I think
you're going to agree will you play tra
Pursuit with the end no that's just fun
would be Pursuit is fun uh Donald Trump
appeals to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court rules it was an
Insurrection and bars him from all
states there there's no way that would
happen I know but it'd be hilarious I
don't think it would be hilarious you
don't think so you get your National
divorce I I I want my national the
reason I use the term National divorce
not the other one is because other one
don't say it I'm not saying it because I
genuinely believe it can be done
peacefully or very relatively peacefully
I am very concerned that even January
6th a slight bit of violence or 911 you
take which was a horrible tragedy and
then 20 years of war in two countries
had nothing to do with it so when you
have this this power establishment in
place any little bit of violence is used
as an excuse by them to escalate things
to the nth threshold threshold and the
average people are the ones to pay the
price and that's what I'm very concerned
about I think we were turning point
someone was it Charlie Kirk or might
have been Tucker Carl I think it was
Tucker said that Winston Churchill in
1940 after World War II broke out he
just arrested all of the opposition
party with no charge they Abraham
Lincoln arrested Lon chur didn't do that
he had a war cabinet say that again
Winston churel had a war cabinet with
the labor party he didn't arrest the
opposing cabinet uh then Tucker Carlson
was wrong he said that on stage that Tu
that uh Winston Churchill went in and
arrested the opposition party just put
them all maybe he meant like some kind
of national front but not the not the
labor party in Maryland you had I think
it was like 29 uh Confederate
sympathetic he rested the legislature
yeah he just went and arested them all
yeah Lincoln they created a uh a
corridor between through through uh
Maryland to DC that suspended all all uh
uh what's the right way to put this um
infringed upon your god-given rights
well wello the idea that you can't seced
except for West Virginia like that
doesn't make any you know what I mean
that whole thing yeah West Virginia is
very special we we're huge fans I'm
curious to see what will happen if the
Colorado GOP does say okay we're not
having a primary more anymore we're
moving to caucus if the RNC at the
national level will come after them for
that because again that's a that's a
move to keep Trump on the ballot which I
think the RNC doesn't ultimately want
either I think Ron McDaniel I think
the's completely right even if she even
if you think she's a great person I
don't know her at all
the fact is where the results like where
where the omelets you broken all these
eggs like and I don't see any Backbone
in her McDaniels in the kitchen smashing
eggs with a hammer telling you she's
going to make an omelet but she's just
smashing eggs with a hammer what would
that look like a pressuring her
she's trying to cook if the Republican
National Convention did a caucus what
would that mean exactly it's not a
convention just the Colorado State col
like I I was the first state they have a
caucus basically you get together and
everyone gets up and gives a speech
about why my guy's the best and then I
think you have a head count I think that
works yep and so it's a bunch of people
sitting in a room and it's like RNC
delegates and things like that business
owners people people show up a lot of
regular people you show up and then if
you're the Democrat you take three days
to figure out what the votes are yeah
but it's because these are in in a
technical legal sense these are private
organizations that can run their systems
as they see fit so when they decide
super delegates and the Democrat side to
push out anybody they want to push out
it's because the game is rigged I also
want to make the point and I'm going to
make the prediction here and I don't
think it's going it's the kind of
prediction people are first like then
they think about like okay this is
actually an easy good prediction I think
the democrat's plan B is not Gavin mome
I think the democrat's plan B is Hillary
Clinton with Nome as VP so I'm I'm
staying it right here if they pull Biden
for some reason or if he's in
capacitated they're going to run Hillary
and they'd be smart to do it $1,000 it
will not be Hillary Clinton uh that if
if Biden's pulled I I'm not making a
real bad I'm kidding I'm making a
reference to uh I got got I felt like
they were kind of teeing up Kamala
Harris no way they Harris I I I don't
know why they would pick her but because
they're sending her on this national
pro-abortion tour she's basically
already on the camp because they don't
want her making trouble in Washington
like stay busy I'm serious did you see
the uh she going on tour they announced
one date they're like we'll tell you the
rest of the get the out of here the
latest the latest clip from her where
she's like this is the most election
we've had in you know in our lifetimes
and I'm just like she meant most
important I guess thing is when your
gaps are worse than Joe Biden's it's
really bad thing can you imagine being a
guy who got put can I use the b word on
the show which one is that b t I don't
know I guess I mean call Dem we don't
care about demonetization the swearing
is usually because like people might be
in their living room with their kids
really in
general I'll say b i I'll say I got I
got I got it can you imagine being some
guy who's in jail in California cuz this
witch put you in jail like you're
watching you're like how the hell did
she convince this jury MH yeah she's
just cackling at my crimes like how
recognize her because of that face lift
right before she came out asvp there's a
hug change so we're going to we were
going to save I was going to I was going
to save this cuz a lot of news to get to
but you know Michael did bring this up
we have this uh map we've talked about a
couple times now this is the a24 Civil
War movie map showing their their vision
of a fictional Civil War now Michael you
just said you think there's a way to
have a peaceful National divorce yes and
I have my own map can I I disagree with
you okay let's you can you can DM me it
can you can you I'll do that right now
send DM me uh I disagree I don't believe
it's possible to have a peaceful civil
divorce a peaceful civil a national
divorce um it happened okay the the
thing about the term peaceful and I hear
what you're saying I'm not saying
literally no violence but I'm saying it
could be the kind of thing that's
resolved quite quickly because a lot of
times just like with like uh nature
right let's use another example you have
like a big animal like a tarer it's a a
Proto Simian I saw a video and it's
trying to eat a praying mantis which is
like a hundredth of its size and that
mantis just strikes for its eyes and
then the tar is like oh crap this is a
problem so a lot of times if there's
enough a push back people go to the
negotiating table that's it no I'm
setting it right now one second so I I
suppose where I I don't think what
you're what you're saying in any way
conflicts with what my view would be
sure you could have a dissolution of the
United States rapidly and very quickly
and then you will see a growing
escalation to fullscale war at some
point and some point relatively quickly
to the dissolution of the United States
there we're talking about uh we already
have conflict between states over
resources over food over water we
already have conflict over weapons when
you consider that some states have
access to nuclear weapons there can't be
a simple dissolution of of these of
these agreements You' you'd instantly
have nuclear powered countries staring
down and facing down country other
states and they might say something like
your state owes us X for these past
Grievances and then you will you will
instantly start to see conflict now I
don't think nuclear weapons are we have
to worry about I think it'll be
absolutely insane considering the dist
distribution of resources in the United
States and what's a really fascinating
idea that I was exploring with um a
creative IP I was I was looking at is as
we hyper centralize the production the
bottom one I sent you to by mistake as
we hyper uh centralize the production of
various
resources like we have the Frack fields
in North Dakota you will end up with
regions dominant in a singular
production so California's food we just
do all our food California basically
like a third a third of our food or
something like that you've got the Frack
fields in North Dakota producing more
energy than any other part of the
country or uh presumably and you have
certain areas that are all Coastal trade
some the Rust Belt I mean maybe it used
to be this way but because of rail
because of freight we've centralized
these resources it's going to be very
strange if the country breaks apart and
one nation or one state says we need oil
and they start knocking on North
Dakota's door North Dakota all of a
sudden becomes one of the wealthiest
states in the world things like that um
when we were on the blaze for election
night I just sent you the sent it twice
by mistake it's the bottom one um we all
asked what this is your map
yeah that's it so that's my map for
National divorce um when we're on the
blaze we all had to go around and say
what we thought it would look like Tim
all your points are taken and I don't
think they're inaccurate at all but I'm
thinking about like North Korea and
South Korea have nukes exping at each
other uh negotiation is not going to be
easy but my I always go back to Thomas
Soul right and the question he asked is
as compared to what I think the status
quo is also going to be Washington
increasingly getting militaristic I
think especially the stuff going on with
schools and kids when you have things
like Sanctuary States for like trans
kids and things like that what
California is going to be doing I think
parents are going to be increasingly
radicalized and so on and so forth and
at a certain point things are going to
reach ahead the question is is it going
to be full-blown uh Blitz cre or is it
going to be like something pops off and
then cooler heads are like okay guys
this is getting crazy and if things get
crazier even further it's really getting
out of hand so we have to figure
something out I think everything you're
saying plays very well to the a24 films
map I I just don't think I I don't see I
we talked about earli do you want to
break it down because I think there's
some things I would tweak with this map
but but yeah so I think the first thing
to consider is when the when the movie
trailer first comes out everyone says
why are Texas in California aligned in
aligned that makes no sense it makes
perfect sense it really does but are
they aligned really yes this is this is
this map is plausible and what that
means is you can certainly make an
argument for why you think it would not
fall this way but in terms of how
they're envisioning this film and what a
divided America could look like I
actually think this is very plausible I
don't know if it's the most probable
there's a lot of arguments that we can
make as as political junkies but the
reason why California and Texas would be
in an alliance is not because they share
values it's because neither wants to be
conquered by DC sure it I I think
Kentucky and Tennessee are extremely
close culturally so to find that line is
really kind of odd to me no in terms of
plausibility you could easily like look
when the Civil War the other thing is
just because they're too they're I can't
I'm blind are they aligned in that
they're the same country or they're just
aligned in like an alliance like New
York like us and Canada are aligned the
Republic of Texas and California are two
different republics that have an
alliance yeah that's that's very
plausible absolutely plaus the case now
yes and you may be arguing you know why
is you know Kentucky and Tennessee split
military occupation by DC and moved in
very quickly into uh into uh Kentucky to
stop uh or into stop the other way
around they move into Tennessee to
prevent Kentucky or vice versa That's
Just DE XM enough for f we can make any
argument about what may happen the point
you made was really key and I think
people didn't to understand this if does
blow out to like full-blown violence and
I pray to God it does not state lines
become irrelevant geographical borders
Rivers ands the Ohio River would be one
the Mississippi River the Rocky
Mountains would be one this Oklahoma
Panhandle is not going to be a thing
it's not possible and and that's why
actually a lot of the Eastern uh uh
state borders would stand yeah because a
lot of them were built uh were formed
simply because of geography uh but I
look you know New England is a joke
right this is one block this whole thing
it's just instantly New York and
Massachusetts I disagree cuz New
Hampshire has a lot of people there and
they've been planning for this
they it's if you have you have SED a
Democrat Governor didn't they yeah but
but the thing is there's differ between
what's uh intensity of of opposition
right so if you have a Cadre of like 10%
of the population who are really out of
their minds and really want New
Hampshire to be inde independent it's
going to be really hard to put those
down you know Luke uh would come here
all the time and advocate for us to move
to New Hampshire because of the free
state project and I'm like my friend you
are surrounded on all sides by leftist
forces I will say there are because like
Upstate New York and like upper Maine
are are different they tend to vote red
I mean obviously Maine has Angus King
one of our only Independents it there
are potential like Rebel factors in
there really I mean he's technically
Hees with democrats for sure I can't
think of but what I I just mean
symbolically like there are there is a a
stratification within those regions I
just don't think it's enough to say that
they would be able to fight off I think
it would be like you were saying before
like Seattle will have this one blue
Center But ultimately that region is
think you would have discontent in New
England but I don't think it would be
enough to manage it and a main new and a
main Democrat or even a Connecticut
Democrat is not the same as an LA
Democrat at all I mean honestly I think
that was more the case 10 years ago but
as you see now with like West Virginia
and you see we we really don't have any
blue dog Democrats anymore correct so
the internet is you know who's the the
one blue dog Democrat who is it my hero
John fedman yeah I guess he's had the
craziest 2023 story arc I I called I I
contribute to his campaign I I spotted
this guy from a mile away you can't miss
him there are funny memes of YouTube
thumbnail the meme is a YouTube th
thumbnail of fedman saying why I left
the
left but in all seriousness fed people
are like how did you predict this guy so
so well John fedman and he is one of
these old school lefties who think the
point of government is to help people
been screwed over by the system whether
it's food stamps or whatever who thinks
politics can be honorable and that
politicians shouldn't be put themselves
on a pedestal and are just like someone
trying to make the world a better place
so that old school Democrat stuff which
is almost kind of in late 60s that's him
so when people are surprised that he's
taking these stances I'm like it makes
perfect sense that he call it corruption
because in his point government is
something that can be used to help
people who have been screwed over and if
that argument is one that I don't hate
and I say this as an anarchist there's a
lot of people who when it comes to the
topic of Civil War like to point out
that uh the entire country is red except
for the cities and that should Civil War
actually happen New York for instance is
red New York City would not be able to
sustain itself uh but I don't I don't I
I I agree with that general idea but
people don't understand
that in Virginia for instance regular
people going to and from work aren't
going to be thinking about this and so
long as there is a weaponized law
enforcement or militaristic faction that
controls trade routes those people will
will be subservient and loyal to
whatever the dominant violent faction is
there's two questions that I would have
to break out one is and everyone says
they have the answer and they don't
because you could say one thing
theoretically when when s hit the fan
it's a very different situation no one
knows what the actual military would do
a lot of people are saying they would
never fire on their own people bull crap
every country has we don't know
percentage though it could be like 100%
of do it 10% how do you work that number
two well just the other point is we
don't know how effective the corporate
press will be in this situation at
manipulating public opinion I think uh
there was there was a a graph that came
out showing the ratings from the past
week did you see it no corporate press
is it's apocalyptic the numbers that are
dropping it's it's it's was really
insane I think like MSNBC dropped 15% in
a week or something like that yeah but
just because you don't trust them if
they're the only people you listen to
you're going to say I hate him but
you're still going to listen to them if
the internet gets shut down yes and it
can be people need to
understand it is possible to disrupt the
internet very very easily the internet
as we know it it is impossible to stop
internet communications but centralized
sources ofation
AIS one for instance where we go to
that's the Hub these things can all be
shut down relatively easily and then all
you have is the New York Times right and
do you believe them and they're and
that's what you will you will that's it
but uh I will
say absolutely the militaries any branch
would shoot American citizens and I
believe in in the event of some kind of
as they have done in the past yeah I
can't State I mean brutal uh and and I
I'm not I'm not arguing it was right or
wrong you can argue but they were
throwing rocks I'm like they shot
Americans it happened like they opened
fire and the guy got one four four dead
shot the as if there wouldn't in this
situation be plenty of false Flags oh
absolutely absolutely and and I want to
drive this point home the most dangerous
thing I think our country faces it's not
the clintons it's not the Democrats it's
not the neol livb it's not the neocon
it's not it's not Trump it's not Trump
certainly not Trump Trump's one of the
more positive forces in my opinion it is
it is one simple thing the biggest start
this country faces
it is the men and women of law
enforcement are armed and the Armed
Forces who hold the ethos I should just
do my job the most dangerous thing
imaginable okay I have just done my job
so I should probably leave because that
that's the song I've been singing I know
I I'm not saying you don't know but I'm
just saying it's just delightful for me
to hear someone who is much more
mainstream in his views and more
moderate than I to see very clearly this
is what it comes you're probably
mainstream but I mean you're you're not
a Queen the far French farri Michael
malice is and the corporate press maybe
or sure sure uh we talked about this
with Owen Shroyer he said when he talk
about a martyr when he went when he went
to prison there were prison guards
saying hey I'm familiar through work I'm
actually a fan but I'm just doing my job
man I would have looked him in the eye
and say you are the evil I'm fighting
against yes if these prison guards went
to their bosses and said I am putting a
hand on Oden Shroyer and I'm not going
to have any party to what you're doing
to him you find somebody else and if
they said I will fire you my response
would be my paycheck is not worth my
soul but do you think that's but they
but they all just said I don't care I'll
lock up a guy I like because I get my
paycheck in that exact point these are
live audio recordings I have I have the
documents but do you think part of it is
that we are a country or people without
clearly defined values I think people
don't really know what they stand for
for it so it's easy to say well I just
have to stand by my payche I think
conservatives very much Advocate and
this is not generally a wrong thing I
think this is actually a good rule in
general to play by the rule rules and be
a good person and not be a troublemaker
but they apply that literally like 100%
of the time and sometimes you want to
make trouble CU otherwise the trouble's
here already I just want to point out
real quick when uh you search Google for
US Civil War the fourth story is Trump
barred from Colorado primary ballot for
role in US capital attack so and that's
from one hour
ago Civil War history never Trump war
first of all what what role did he have
even allegedly he said go over there
peacefully make your voice heard this is
first and then he said respect law
enforcement we respect law enforcement
everyone should go home but but he's
crazy he was out of control assembling a
crowd I I I I don't like the Democrats
and what they're doing there's a lot of
Republicans I also don't like but
there's a handful that are that are that
are okay but none of that terrifies me
what terrifies me is police officers US
service men and women and prison guards
who know they're they're standing
alongside the devil and and and you can
call that figurative or literal if you
are someone of of Faith it's you view it
as literal we can call as literal you
can view it as spiritual or as as
pragmatic I'm saying quite literally
when I heard that from Owen
Shroyer these prison guards may as well
have been the demons fighting alongside
Satan himself they know what they're
doing is wrong they know they're on the
on the side of evil and they don't care
and here's the other thing it would be
one thing they got a family to
if they tried looking for other jobs
nothing came up and it's like look it's
either this or my kid starve then I
could that's fine but they haven't tried
looking for other jobs and the other
thing is I've modulated my views on the
police a little bit because I've spent
way too much time watching police body
cam footage on YouTube and apparently
now snuff films are a thing just go on
YouTube and watch people get murdered
their channels dedicated nothing but
yeah and a lot of times you you respect
the police a lot more because they're
dealing with an absolute Maniac who's
just just complet and they have to be
like sir or ma'am and it's just like I
feel like this is your job I feel for
you but then there's videos of some
mentally disabled Guy having a problem
at Target with the uh um self checkout
and they're just manhandling him and and
what and the guy's like in this voice
being like I didn't do anything and I'm
like if you're putting your hands on
someone who is mentally disabled or
elderly or a child because they're
having a problem with the cashier yeah
why did Target call this to begin with
okay it's a separate question and you
can look at yourself in the mirror
you're you are a demon I mean it this is
why the country is falling apart you
have many of these leftists and
Democrats that want to abolish the
police but I mean I think the fair point
is they want to abolish policing that's
the thing you and I want to abolish hold
on let me say one thing we want to
abolish the police and that we don't
want a Government monopoly but they
don't want people to be put in jail well
I actually disagree my point I was going
to make is they will actually say
whatever they need to say oh sure that's
fair I'm yes yeah they they'll say today
these police are evil then when the cops
come and mercilessly beat you they'll
laugh while it happens yeah oh yeah when
the cops arrest D chin they clap in
cheer look at Jimmy okay here's another
example look at Jimmy Kimmel who's
crying because his kid was sick and I
don't want this almost anybody and my
heart goes out to that kid and then he's
literally laughing like you didn't get
vaccinated and you go to the hospital
and you're not getting treatment sorry
coffee and the audience laughs and it's
just like you're you're a demon yeah I'm
I'm I'm I'm done defending these people
I'm I'm not I'm not going to say
anything about his child I'm done
defending them or saying anything nice
about them I I had this view in in the
2010s about free speech
where I was like we have to defend Free
Speech even for the people that that we
don't like because the point of free
speech and so you had these leftists and
these woke people saying No Free Speech
then they would get censored and I'd
come out along with everyone else and
say unban them that was wrong we believe
in free speech they would get unbanned
and say thank you immediately then go
now ban them and then I had the
realization you know what Free Speech
extends to those who believe in free
speech end of story if these people come
out and they cry what about my free
speech speech I'll say you don't deserve
it because you don't want it I will give
you exactly what you ask for if they
start Banning people who believe in free
speech I will advocate for their Free
Speech but I will not defend people who
are trying to Burn It To The Ground well
when Frank herberts had this great quote
in Dune he goes when I'm weaker than you
I asked from freedom because that is
according to your principles and when
I'm stronger than you I take away your
freedom because that is according to my
principles exct that's exactly thing uh
I've never been for free speech I hate
that term I've always thought freedom of
Association is much more important than
Free Speech if you want to go talk in
some closet and have microphone that's
fine but there's plenty of reasons why I
don't want you on my platform I don't
want to be associated with you if only
cuz you're just obnoxious bring nothing
to the table let's jump to this next
story from the post millennial
California moves to explore every legal
option to get Trump off the 2024 ballot
by December 28th guys okay Michael I'm
going on vacation right this this we
wrap Friday and then I'm gone we got to
get one week out of the year and they're
trying to make Trump kicked off the
ballot in during my vacation what what
am I'm going to do they knew you were
leaving and they're like this is our
time but hold on here's something else
say interesting and there's something to
think about I don't think Gavin is dumb
I think he is strategic in many ways
they there's zero chance Trump wins
California so this is clearly them
building steps for the future because
he's not at all concerned Trump is going
to be get California's but that's not
what it's about it's about 10 million
Republican votes in California that
count towards Trump's uh uh general
election and so what's going to happen
is Donald Trump will win the electoral
college with 50 million to Joe Biden or
whoever is 70 million then they will
then the Democrats will come out
screaming being like ladies and
gentlemen the man who is currently
giving the GI given the nuclear football
right does not represent this country
they say that now with the Senate of
course like oh like why it's not fair
that West Virginia has the same number
of Senators as California well it's
actually is fair they each have equal
numbers because they States that's why
they did it that that was the purpose
the point as they know as they know yep
so I think you know what is I'm sorry
what one more thing Tim the thing about
Free Speech free speech is great if
people are arguing in good faith but and
there's difference between someone who's
just a leftist as Progressive views and
there's lots of people and there's many
strong Arguments for progressivism
things like this that are be done on
political government level are not being
done in good faith this is that's the
difference this is the bigger issue with
getting Trump's name off the ballot
removing him from the primaries on super
Tuesday
yeah they don't think Trump will win a
general election they would strip him of
popular vote totals but more
importantly they remov Trump from the
ballot before the primary Nikki Haley is
the nominee but also they can dis way
just say any look if you're a member of
the NRA you're an insurrectionist you
can't run for office yeah it's just that
easy I look I just don't see any future
that doesn't
involve if it's not a civil war it's a
totalitarian revolution of some sort
it's a Bic Revolution I I I strongly
disagree that those are the only two
things on the table I'm not saying only
oh okay sorry okay I'm I'm saying like
there is no return to normaly but here
it was never normal we were just
brainwashed to thinking was normal I
understand that but we had a period when
I mean is for for those of us between
the ages of you know let's just say 20
and 40 we had a system that is gone and
what what we are going into will be 100
times more extreme and more tumultuous
than anything we've experienced I agree
with that completely and that's a good
thing I think that's necessary I think
you need the enema to get rid of the
poop yeah be a shortterm relatively
short-term bout of chaos no I don't
think short-term well what you got to
Define it could be 15 years that well
that's pretty long term that would be
short term in my opinion well the Civil
War is only four yeah but I mean I'm
talking like real Global American
Revolution was 20 is that transformation
was 20 20 the American revolutionary
period was 20 years yeah the uh well the
period not the whole War the the but but
the but the war I I think the idea of
the Revolutionary War is is less
meaningful than the revolutionary period
like the Boston yes that's fair the
Boston Tea Party Like Red Coats were
killing people before there was a war
that's fair so we talk about the war but
the revolutionary period was 20 years
and um the uh what is it the first
battle of the Revolutionary War took
place a year and a few months before the
signing of the Declaration of
Independence it's funny that a lot of
people think the signing of the
Declaration started the the revolution
It's like because they get 10 years
later wait but they get it in history
textbook and I'm not GNA fault this
where it's all stacked on top of each
other it's it's very hard to concept
narrative the Nar makes sense that way
that's that's sort of true it history is
condensed but no I think the reality is
people just don't read history they hear
what do we know the holiday July 4th why
because in 1776 they signed the
Declaration of dependence do you know
what the actual date of the signing was
the what the Declaration of dependence
no what the second was it yeah and then
uh or it may have actually been before
that I believe it was the second and
then it took uh days to get everyone
sign it I I don't I don't even know no I
think it was signed on the second and
then it was uh not in
circulation and publicly known until the
4th yeah but I could be wrong but
something like that if you read books
you would think that there's only two
genders and no scientist thinks this
anymore not the ones allow to practice
sorry I just want to mess with the chat
room so but but but anyway back to the
uh back to what's going on with
California let me ask you if uh Trump is
removed from these
ballots Nikki Haley
there is there is I I I don't think
Trump getting roof in the ballots then
it's just like well we're just going to
go ahead with the election and it's it's
whatever whoever Plan B is for the
Republicans that's not how it works I
think things are going to get very very
ugly very very quickly uh I will be
paying rosan in that circumstance I
think we might have I don't know what it
would look like we got to get into this
but um you may have to pay her you know
we're going to talk about that well
we'll we'll we'll we'll get into that
for those that aren't familiar uh
Rosanne said on this show how long ago
that was few few months ago wow long
time ago Rosanne said wow I can't
believe how long it's been I think so
yeah Rosanne said that she didn't think
there'd be an election there are two
bets we made that's right military
tribunals everyone everyone remembers
the second bet they're they're all
forgetting the first bet I think you won
the first one yeah no no no no she
said what did she say she said there'll
be Mass arrests by the end of the year
yeah that's not happening I but hold on
we have a couple weeks left right hold
on she said Trump would there would be M
military tribunals and I'm like you're
saying Trump will have people arrested
like or the Democrats are going to
arrest people I'll take either if either
case I'll give her $1 th000 do if the
Democrats have mass arrest she wins fine
that's true too in the next week okay
well that's not that's not zero perc
that's not zero it's not zero no no no
it's not zero I'm not saying it's zero
but anyway uh someone also bet me that
Trump and my my buddy who's a failed
podcaster Tom Woods someone on Twitter
bet me $500 that Trump would be
reinstated in the White House by January
1st 2024 not 2025 meaning they would
overturn the 2020 election and have
Trump in the White House by 20 24 now
there's a non-zero chance that'll happen
next week but I'm looking no that's
that's zero right the idea that
Democrats would arrest people they've
already arrested Trump and Trump's legal
team and you know his lawyers and other
people involved so the idea that the
Democrats would stage Mass arrests is
like maybe like
05 that's fair but the idea that Trump
has reinstated is like okay fine it's in
it's in the realm of physical real
but like we're talking
0.00000000 1% right it would be more
likely that like the secretary Commerce
becomes president like everyone else
gets knocked off yeah it'd be more
likely that the plot of designated
Survivor happens Line forline Reality
exactly yes I just come on no I like
that show but it went off the rail so
quickly oh I don't know I didn't watch
it I just know the general premise like
everybody dies but him and they're like
your president he's like why like you're
like 100th in line so you're in charge
here it's like well you're here I guess
that makes it you and uh and here we go
uh so so what do you think you think
that if California actually makes the
move as well or well they are making the
move I know right but I'm saying like
but what are they make what moves have
they taken did Gavin just call it or no
no lieutenant governor said Trump should
be removed for the same reason okay and
she it was really funny because she said
you she everyone knows you have to be 40
years old and cannot have staged an
Insurrection or whatever and everyone's
like neither of those are true like the
fascinating thing about Colorado's
ruling Supreme Court of Colorado is that
the third uh article three of the 14th
Amendment actually does not include the
president and they even said it in their
ruling they said it's just self-evident
that's not how the law works you don't
get to be like well the law doesn't say
we can arrest you but we think they
intended that it's pretty obvious right
you're under arrest the law is whatever
those in power decide the law is yes as
people are learning Steve D is really
good about this he goes this has always
been I was shocked that someone who's a
conservative and not Anarchist can be
like this is a country of Will and not
laws and it always has been the
anarchist perspective yeah the idea that
Free Speech ex existed in this country
at any point is
laughable uh the the Sedition Act
president Adams were arresting
journalists for criticizing the
government first thing and and and not
just that we had obscenity laws George
Carlin got arrested for swearing yes so
if you want if you want to make
arguments about the limits of of free
speech and it's it's been better than
it's been in a long time and it's not a
function of the Constitution which has
not changed it's been a function of the
culture which is always more important
than any piece of paper that's why we
make you know songs yes that's why we we
make skate videos that's why it's so
important what the daily wire is doing
and you know a lot of people I hear will
say things like uh oh I want to get
involved in the fight so I'm going to do
a podcast and I'm like well I got to be
honest like we probably got too many of
those you know some may be better than
others but what we need is music video
games and TV shows movies comedy you
know why it's important because there
has to be as little or no social cost
for opting out if you have Alternatives
where I can play video G games I like
gamergate I just want to play video
games where I can play video games and
get action figures and get laid and
watch programs and not be involved with
their whole edifice then we've won yeah
that's the plan man I think it's
happening don't you think it's happening
more and more I agree I agree I think
with the major boycotts we saw of this
year we are with Disney's failures do
you not think hold on let me interrupt
do you not think it's hilarious I mean I
that John fedman handed over case of Bud
Light to whoever it was was that not
funny well what do you think about the
Bud Light thing right now what what's
happening now well so right now kid
Rocka said it's over he said we gave him
a black eye it's what they deserved I
think we're good uh Joe Rogan laughed
said it was stupid and then bought uh
several cases of Bud Light out and drank
them with with some comedians like Shane
Gillis I think they posted a photo of it
and uh Dana White says they're align
with you more than you realize and
everyone who who believes in this
country should go out and buy Bud
Light
um the Matt Matt Walsh has come out and
said no the boycot still on hold the
line
I don't understand the point of pulling
a boycott here's let's let's take
something out of this let's a little
unpolitical way do you have any siblings
Ian yeah two brother or sister two
brothers okay let's suppose I'm on a
podcast and I say an insulting thing
about your brother is a dumb joke and
you you come to me you go you you
shouldn't have said it hurt his feelings
and I felt bad about it and I'd be like
you know what that was screwed up I'm
sorry I would apologize to you I would
ask your brother for an apology I'd be
like here here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to keep his name out of my
mouth for the future because I don't
want to hurt his feeling he didn't
deserve that in that case you would
accept my apology CU you you know what I
made a stupid joke I didn't mean it harm
was done and it was resolved maybe I'd
give him like a say hey bye beer on my
behalf right you have when you to
forgive someone they have to apologize
and acknowledge what they did wrong and
own it maybe let me give you another
scenario in my opinion uh do you have
any siblings yes uh a sister sister uh
which is terrible okay so Ian Praises
your
sister that's you got out there pretty
creative what have I done okay let's
let's let's for real so so you insult
you know Ian's brother yeah and Ian says
hey you shouldn't have done that that's
that that was mean and you shouldn't say
it so you go okay give your brother $100
on me and $100 to you we'll be done with
it should he say okay or should he be
like no I don't want your money I want
you I want your apology I think it
depends on our relationship if he could
tell I really do feel bad also I'm
giving you just go buy dinner on me then
that's different but if he's no apology
you just say you you just privately say
okay well how about I give you a 100
bucks and we'll we'll call my Integrity
is not worth $100 I'd be like keep your
money and you don't have to say anything
about my brother but I know who you are
now and the apology acknowledges that
there was wrong done yes that's the
thing you have to be exp cash is saying
please stop talking about this yeah go
away I'm Pay Here's my concern right now
let's ask Ian what he thinks your
brother outside of outside of the the
the brother analogy I understand your
point the concern I have with the
budlight thing is you've lost Joe Rogan
you've lost Kid Rock you've lost Dana
White uh and we have seen some political
gains I I don't really care about
platitudes so what have we seen $100
million goes to UFC you end up with
people like Sean Strickland coming out
saying uh you I'll I'll just tell you
what he said he said that trans people
should not they should not be accepted
by what what they're going through
should not be accepted by
Society but my the point with he said a
bunch of things that like you can't say
on YouTube and he said sponsored by Bud
Light he also just tweeted that January
6 is the most patriotic thing that this
country has has done in a long time
that's better this is a guy who was
saying thank you budlight for sponsoring
my speech and allowing me to say this I
view that as on par with what they did
with Dylan Mulan so it's sort of a moot
you know neutralizing force in a certain
degree but my bigger concern is if the
catalyzing forces of the boycott have
basically bowed out that means you've
lost a few generals sure what's going to
happen is come April the wraparound for
year-to-year profits is going to hit Bud
light's going to report earnings they're
going to see a net positive gain because
it's year-over-year their their stock is
already recovered they're going to
declare victory over the boycott so what
I'm saying is either you join with the
likes of Joe Rogan and Kid Rock Dana
White and Shan Strickland and say hahaa
we've won declare victory over your
enemies but or if you do want to
maintain the boycott and double down you
need an advancing strategy how are you
going to get them to apologize uh I I
can't remember who was tweeting about
this it um who was tweeting about this
they said we we would need to see I
think it might have been James Lindsay
um test testimony before Congress as to
how this happened Republicans call them
in and say what was this that caused
damage to the shareholders Victory and
lawsuits but the idea that we simply
just don't do anything and that's what a
boyat is we don't buy their product and
we just it go on with our lives I think
is is is not an option so there's been a
divide in this many people saying Hold
the Line keep the boycott up and I say
okay what's the next plan what's the
next move because if you do nothing
they'll take back the battlefield I I
agree broadly speaking but I'm just
going to make one point I know people
are going to melt down I don't think
what budlight did is as bad as what some
of these other companies are doing like
when you're talking okay it's a trans
influencer we made a like a custom
bottle can for for for d m great that's
one thing well that wasn't the issue
hold on just one more thing when you
have things like Target with like
tucking panties for kids like that's but
Target's so much harder for people that
also did not happen what happened then
please the talking was for adults okay
still the concern is that they have all
of this stuff front and center and
available for children they had gender
neutral swim yes talking I apologize to
Target that's a bad example I'm saying
you still don't have to apologize for
them make sure I want to be c i I want
to speak correctly so I don't want to be
like Target you know I'm glad that you
corrected me what I'm saying is there's
other organizations that do things that
are far more malevolent then take
someone who's already an influencer and
make them it's like a oneoff thing I got
to C you on budlight it wasn't that
Delan M got a can it's that Dyan Mia was
hired and paid what is the report is
$180,000 to promote Bud Light and a
contest they were doing doing I'm just
saying it's important because the I'm
saying it's people think that you could
go to Walmart and get a Dy Maly can you
could not have done that it was a custom
can just for Dylan but that's not what
anyone's mad about the corporate press
claimed that was the the cause of the
boycott it was not the cause of the
boycott was that Dylan Mulaney grabbed a
stack of budlight put them on the table
and said everyone buy budlight and use
this hashtag to win a contest hashtag
whatever I don't March Madness or
something was paid According to some
some reports $180,000 and Del M Del M's
audience's children
so people were like why are they
promoting this gender ideology stuff and
why are they promoting it to Children
the media then immediately ran out and
said budlight gave a custom can to one
person and the right lost their mind to
obate and lie about what happened Fair
my point is there are many such cases
where they are targeting children not
via somebody but directly oh yeah and
like when you have these Publishers who
are publishing these books that have
pornographic content for kids they are
to me are much more malevolent than some
Dyan malany F there's a big story right
now daily wire tweeting about it and
Wess tweeted it it's a Coco melon is
that what it's called where it's an
interracial gay couple singing to their
son who's dancing in girls clothing and
so you know daily wire of course saying
this is why we made bent key we'll talk
about that in the members only show so
we can get more in depth because I do
want to I I do want to get back to the
politics going on can I say one more
thing it's also important in terms of
boycotts things like this to pick your
battles because it's much more useful to
take down someone who is both much more
evil and who you can win than somewhere
it's just like you know like water for
ducks back my my view on Bud Light is
and I hate I I don't understand everyone
drinks Bud Light to begin with maybe
snob and like I'm not going to buy it
you know like when we we don't we don't
even buy sodas we buy the spin dffs cuz
it's like 17 calories fruit juices I've
got my Dr Pepper zero that's disgusting
it's it's my primary method of hydration
not I'm not kidding at all my my P is
jet black well we let's jump to the
politics let's get back to the primary
discussion we've got this ladies and
gentlemen I am going to say this
unequivocally Rhonda santis has disqual
ified himself there is no circumstance
in which I will vote for this man what
you g him you going to get him off the
ballot no no he he can do whatever he
wants take a look at this video let me
play it for you and you can hear it for
yourself do we have the audio queued up
and real quick fellow GOP 2024
presidential candidate VC ramaswami
saying he will remove himself from the
Colorado ballot unless Trump's
eligibility is restored would you do the
same no I think that's just playing into
the left um I think the case will get
overturned by the Supreme Court but I've
qualified for all the ballots I'm
competing in all the states and I'm
going to accumulate the delegates
necessary that's the whole name of the
game in this situation but I do
anticipate that that decision was
political and will get
reversed all right Governor run for that
he has disqualified himself do you know
what VI is really really good at VI is
really maybe this he's read too much
Robert Green 48 loss of power he's
really good at making these bold power
moves and forcing everyone else to react
to what he's doing that to me is
strategy at its finest we have to
address this Ronda Santa says that's
playing into the left that makes no
sense it literally makes no sense makes
no sense if the move of the left is to
remove Donald Trump so that someone else
wins the primary Ron said I know what
they did is political and I have secured
the delegates and that's the game and if
you want to be really pedantic the
California Supreme Court and the left
are not synonymous because there's lots
of leftists color Supreme Court sorry
Colorado there's lots of leftists who
are I know like people on Twitter freak
out there's lots of leftists who are pro
democracy in this sense who find this
unable I I will call out look Tucker
Robert Kenny Jr is not a right winger he
he's like this is crazy Tucker Carlson
said on IRL on Monday at tpusa that the
people representing Ron desandis online
are some of the nastiest Zero Sum people
he's ever seen and instantly they all
lose their minds can you name names cuz
who's he referring to well because
someone I'm friends with like Laura
lommer I like Laura right she goes for
the juggler every time does she work for
Trump no no I'm not Christina Pasa okay
she's Ron second in command sure she she
she she on the internet behaves as
though she and Laura lummer are the
exact same person doing the exact same
things okay and now at first I said now
hold on there just gosh darn minute in
that voice in that voice Laura lomer is
just a fan of trump right and Christina
Pasha is is Ron's second in command for
what reason is the the like press
campaign press secretary and second in
command arguing with of Donald Trump and
that's the world they live in so at
first I say this doesn't reflect on on
on Des STIs in terms of the nastiness of
his supporters online but the fact that
he won't fire them absolutely does so
when Tucker said it doesn't reflect on
Ron but these people are B absolutely
does of course why won't he fire red
fern Griffin and and Pasha if Ian was on
on Twitter like spouting Nazi ideology
and you're going to be like well it's
his opinion like that's crazy depending
but I got to be honest like we have a
very strong Free Speech B
compan but you're you're right and I've
said this over and over again there's a
threshold I'm willing to tolerate I I I
I I have said free speech not for those
who don't believe in free speech anybody
wants to come in here advocate for
Fascism and taking away people's rights
I'm going to say I'm not going to defend
yours you don't or at least I'm not at
least I don't have to hire you it's
freedom of Association you hire and work
with whoever you want yeah Ronda Sanz is
here he said it the the last part of
this is the most important part not the
I won't remove myself whatever the last
part of this is what matters play it
again no I think that's just playing
into the left um I think that that was
meaningless by the way makes no sense
but anyway the case will get overturned
by the Supreme Court but I've qualified
for all the ballots I'm competing in all
the states and I'm going to accumulate
the delegates necessary that's the whole
name of the game in this situation the
whole name of the game is for him to
accumulate the delegates he will not
remove himself even if Trump has has
been removed he thinks Trump will be put
back on it's political I'm getting all
these desandis people saying oh yeah but
you know he's saying he knows it'll be
overturned I'm like that's meaningless
if that were true and he thought 100%
Trump would be back on the ballot then
he would say VI's right I I will
absolutely remove myself from the
primary process because it's not a real
race no he said the opposite he said the
name of the game is getting delegates
and I'm not backing down I'm going to
win he he is no different than a
Democrat I have seen not one time in
this primary where Ronda santis did a
bold move or took a strong stand on
anything which is shocking to me no it
would have been more interesting if he
beat vake to the punch here right
because that's the thing now V who knows
everyone else there we talk about all
the time Republicans are not unified
there are a bunch of people who
obviously don't want Trump to become the
nominee theoretically V included right
because he's campaigning for president
so he was the first one to say well I
would leave it and now all of them who
actually don't want to leave the race
either follow suit meaning that he is
the leader or they argue and then they
see anti Trump which isolates the base
his entire governorship is bold move
bold move leftist freak out headline
bold move bold move bold move but as but
he's running as you would think a Nikki
Haley candidacy would be run he's
running worse than Nikki Haley worse but
I mean I don't understand and what I see
is I didn't support Donald Trump in 2016
I we have criticisms on this show of
trump we have debates over police as an
institution abolition of police we have
we have fairly nuanced conversations the
left doesn't want to come on the show
well screw them they don't have to but
they should and when it comes to the
likes of Donald Trump as I said uh Luke
rowski will come on here and critic
Trump to no end even at one point saying
he wouldn't vote for him and then he
sure enough went and voted for him Luke
voted Luke says he voted for
Trump okay I guess guess we know who the
real Anarchist is after all that's right
that's right but my point is this me
Michael you have yeah your brother I
hate him you have Ronda sanz's
supporters prominent journalists and
personalities and personal the daily
wire who are saying things that come off
as the most
pathetic desperate lies to defend Ronda
Sanz Matt Walsh C said something that I
thought was just it was cringe he
criticized V saying what's the point of
doing this blah blah blah and I'm like
it is the most unbelievable thing and
inauthentic thing a person could say
acting as though they don't understand
what VI was doing right we all get it VI
is in third place in the Lesser known
GOP debates he's in fourth place in the
primary and he's still doing power moves
and we know exactly why he's doing it to
act like you think it makes no sense is
in my opinion it's cringe man there
there there are journalists that we've
had on the show obviously we're friends
with Matt we I like the guy I think he's
fantastic but I'll criticize who I think
deserves it and they're they're on
Twitter Dave Rubin acting like Ronda did
the right thing here and I'm like dude I
don't care what you think okay we can be
friends we can have dinner that's kind
of the point but no one believes you
when you come out and you're like I
think Ron did the right thing you don't
believe that now you're losing all your
credibility because he's outright saying
he's going to win the delegates after
they removed Trump from the race and
that's the game no it isn't and here's
the thing isn't Colorado way down the
line in terms of when they actually
super Tuesday yeah so like Colorado is
not going to be determinative in any
case by super Tuesday it's probably
going to be close to wrapped up maybe
they down to two people right so this
wouldn't even cost him anything else if
he on the other hand let's play devil
I'll me let me play devil Devil's AF
with you what if the concern with Des
santis is that VI is being the leader
among the plan B people and if Ron
agrees with him that's going to be used
as look Ronda santz can't even leave
within within the primary yep and and V
at least in the 538 polls uh after the
last debate he jumped over Christy
Christy and he were sort of neck and
neck and he's he's jumped that's bad for
he must have had some kind of big pogo
stick I think part yeah that's true but
SE those extreme pogos oh yeah where
they do flips and stuff that's super
cool I think part of it is that V has uh
Charisma and when he's on stage he can
really command attention right he had
his like got nothing to lose right and
so at this point why not I mean the the
thought what I heard from some people
was like it's easy to say I'll come off
the ballot when you think they're going
to terminate their campaign anyways
which also puts him in a strong position
it's one of the reasons that people want
Donald Trump back in the white house
because he could only serve one more
term anyways so imagine what he would do
uh it's a very similar mindset and I
think again that's a threat to dis STIs
let me give you an example Ryan cedra he
said in response I said I I tweeted no
one SE no one honest sees anything other
than Ron trying to win power if he
really believed it he would uh it would
be overturned he would agree with v so
Vedra tweeted one Trump's team filed a
lawsuit to have DeSantis thrown off the
ballot which Tim pool ignores this is
why I despise these people sorry Ryan
this is the cringiest most despicable
thing is Ry a d santis person yes okay
when this happened we all talked about
it you want me to go back to May and be
like well I know it's happening now with
Trump but let's go back in time 6 months
to discuss an old old news story that's
not relevant right now well of course we
talked about it whenever these stories
come up we talk about it the whole
debate we had was over whether or not
Ron first it's whether Ron could be
Trump's VP that qu that's out of the
question and whether or not Ron was in
violation of laws pertaining to using
his funds from from from the governor's
race for the presidential race and we've
had numerous conversations about his
staff working between the campaign and
his uh and his office that conversation
happens all the time and now he's like
Tim ignores it they're just lying
and anyone hold on let me let I don't
know Ryan but let it could be that he
just doesn't know so he doesn't mean
he's lying he just could be ignorant why
is he bringing up a story from May
because in this case it's showing that
he's trying to claim that Trump's being
a hypocrite so he's claiming I'm a
hypocrite no he he could be play ignes
he could be playing that in terms of him
not knowing your record as opposed to
lying so he's making instead of looking
into it at all correct he maybe he was
lazy I'm so he's fabricating more lazy I
I I I I don't accept lazy okay that's F
considering considering the fact that
Ron's supporters have this this is their
MMO this is one example I as well as you
do okay th this is no matter what Ron
does there's some defense for it okay
when we had Laura lommer and Bill
Mitchell on debating Trump Vita santis I
yeah I asked Bill Mitchell why are the
STIs people attacking me and he says
Laura lomer tweeted and Alex Bruce witz
and I said Bill stop I'm not Laura lomer
I'm not Al BR witz why are they tweeting
at me and he goes Laura lomer and I said
I don't care hair why are you Tweeting
at me this is what they do they they
they see something from a fan of Trumps
they grab onto it and then they make
up so this is a topical news
program When Donald Trump was
challenging Des sanus of course we
talked about it we talked about it in
numerous contexts there's no reason to
say this other than you're trying to
mislead your audience and act like we
don't care that Trump does these things
when Laura lomer tweeted a a fake tweet
we presume from Christina Pasha that
Christina pasa tweeted the same thing I
said the desis campaign the desis people
are the scumbags they claim Trump are
they immediately ran with it but Trump
doesn't care Tim doesn't care when Trump
does it I said is Laura lommer on
Trump's
campaign and they all they all think
this is the this is why I say okay I'm
done with these people they view
themselves like we are on stage at a
rock concert and Donald Trump is here
and I thought Ronda Sanz was up here
with us and we were debating what the
next song in the set was going to be I
now realize thanks to the dis santis
fans Donald Trump is up on stage we're
standing here behind him cheering him on
and down there in the audience in the
mosh pit arguing with you know with Rick
who's selling cotton candy is Ronda
santis in his campaign and they're
screaming at us on stage and I said ah
why am I even bothering talking to these
people I shouldn't be yelling down to
the to the audience and the fans let let
them watch the show and do their thing
Ronda Sanz is not a serious Contender
his influencers are not even viewing
themselves as is on par with the Trump
campaign so we shouldn't even be
debating him he's
done well I think he is I think the fact
seems pretty clear that his campaign's
just completely imploded and I've never
seen anything like it in my lifetime
probably and he's never gained I mean
Trump is still polling at like what 60%
there no one has been able to close that
Gap here's the question for the table
and I can go either way but I I'm
leaning to towards one one way or the
other the answer is is this 40 chess
from the Democratic establishment to
force Trump to be the nominee thinking
he'd be much more beatable if he's got
felonies that was one of the things the
santis said today you got this pollster
I think this was um who was this this
was uh what's his face what's the
polster's name that no one cares about
anymore Frank Lun was that was this Lun
who said this yeah Lun he said uh this
Supreme Court ruling from uh uh Colorado
Trump is now more likely to beat Biden
because of this yeah but what I'm saying
is that is just cuz they're playing 4 d
chess doesn't mean they're good at it so
in their thinking their Normie thinking
they could be like no one's going to
vote for for a felon no one's going to
vote for blah blah blah no one's going
to vote for they all this this was their
2016 strategy once we make right once we
make him out to be a white nationalist
Nazi no one's going to vote for him it's
going to be clear you have to vote for
Hillary and basically the message was
every single day you have to vote for
Hillary you have to go for Hillary every
right thinking person is voting for
Hillary just ask us and then everyone
voted in went into the booth and raised
their finger said nah you know that in
swing States not only does Trump have a
lead uh I think he's leading in seven
and tied in two
but some are double digit double digits
but more importantly among people who
did not vote in 2020 Trump holds a 40%
lead in Michigan and like a 27% lead in
Georgia C holy crap new voters swinging
towards Trump you know
why the rent's too damn High
yeah you should have him on the show Jim
McMillan if he's still alive it is the
cost of food uh there's a meme that's
going around I love it you know the who
radicalized you meme and like NPC the
new one is a guy saying angrily saying
my grocery bill it's it's a picture of a
rece yeah yo we I went out to Ed we went
to a Mexican restaurant today I got we
got fajitas guacamole and a Pusa how
much you think that cost $37 what do you
think I I I I I don't even really know
what half those things are may it was 36
just for the let me sit down restaurant
we went to sit down7 let me let me let
me give you guys a a painted picture it
was
approximately I don't know what 3 or 400
no 300 ft maybe 200 ft small okay uh I
would estimate 8 to 12 tables okay I
know those those types yeah with fast
casual bar style small Mexican
restaurant around here yeah okay so not
a high class sit down we're talking wood
chairs and a table so fajo I would guess
chicken fajitas so this is chicken
breast over I don't so chicken are $.95
I would guess what are the other two
things we ordered guacamole guacamole is
$8.95 and Pusa I don't know what that is
it is a stuffed flower tortilla Ohi
that's going to be $6.95 I would say and
plantains plantains will be what like
also uh what do you think the total cost
so 12 13 plus 12 25 plus so like 34 yeah
my guess was up there at 34 but now but
I'm thinking of inflation I'm looking at
I feel like it's like $65 $18 fajita is
57 bucks no 47 47 bucks wow that's a
third more than than it would have been
like not that long ago
$47.50 not a high-end restaurant I mean
I'm not trying to disrespect this
restaurant it was really good food um
but this was a local small like it was a
strip mall a strip mall uh me you know
why this makes me so angry and this is
why I'm very like End the Fed and all
this other stuff because inflation is a
tax on poverty yes it hurts poor people
first and foremost and and it just
drives me crazy Michel do you think that
uh you know this but let me just stress
this for the people listening inflation
is good for the wealthy you you you want
to know what the what the wealthy love
about inflation when the costs go up it
means their net worth goes up yeah right
but a poor person who needs to buy
chicken and they're not making enough
money they can't buy that food for their
family now for the for the for the
wealthy investor they're like what's
inflation at oh so what's what's what's
my property at wow my car is up 7% my my
house is up 7% the the the hard assets
we own from our you know insert you know
Factory building whatever all all those
are more expensive now is your mom an
immigrant
no okay when we came to this country I
my mom told me how we had so little
money like on on 86 Street in venson Hur
in Brooklyn you have a lot of fruit
stands and she'd go to the Fruit stand
on on uh the west side of the all the
way west see how much the grapes were
walk all the way to the other side this
down the block and it's not a short
block these are Avenues in Brooklyn see
how much the grapes were and if it's
like a 5-cent difference she would do it
and that's the kind of thing when you're
like really poor you have to make these
considerations so it it like there's few
things that get me like really really
really enraged and the flippancy with
which inflation is talked about is if
like oh it's going to be warmer tomorrow
it's like these are people having make
sacrifice about they have to wake up
half an hour earlier to get to work
because they can't afford like some kind
search pricing or something for the
bridge or it's it's so gross you know I
I I did a couple of books with DL hugley
and one of the points he made which
really kind of resonate with me and I
don't agree with him specifically but he
goes you know this country hates poor
people and I don't think that's true but
it sure doesn't love them and doesn't
out for them it doesn't and especially
people who are in power you know the
Lefty lefties traditionally at their
best are the bleeding hearts who are
like oh you know someone's hungry let's
get them fed let's get them clothes you
know let's look out for them and like we
you'd laugh at that but it's like you
know what the older I get the less I
laugh at that and the more I'm like we
can use a little bit more of that and it
really sickens me how much poor people
aren't thought of in this country cuz
they don't have much power by definition
they're used as weapons the immigrants
are are the poor new poor people that
are being taken care of by the
government it's the people that are
coming across the border being flown
well they they don't come over here with
anything as far as they do it cost them
thousands of dollars to hire these
coyotes some of these people coming from
North Africa have 10 grand Sometimes
they come in and they owed they have to
pay that back after they get here yeah
sometimes but when we're looking at
North African migrants who paid uh
Smugglers
$5,000 that's more than a lot of people
in this country could afford to spend on
on on moving now to be fair yes they get
here now they don't have anything
perhaps they shouldn't have spent five
you know between three and 5 grand or
even upwards of 10 depending on who
they're with to come to this country and
now the fascinating thing is we've got
these videos coming out from like Ashley
stclair Nuance bro had a video and uh
Taylor Hansen from tenant these people
are giving being given premium economy
they're being flown in the premium seats
on airplanes yeah that's to their choice
of destination you flew me coach here
you POS well are you a migrant yeah did
you cross the border and I I'm a refugee
we will reimburse you the difference and
get you a first class on the way back
I'll tell I'm not Joe Biden I'll tell
you a funny story I when I left New York
for Austin oneway ticket I'm like you
know what I'm going to treat myself I'm
going to get first class and the
armrests are too far apart cuz I'm a
munchkin and I'm like I wasted money for
nothing you can't even use the arm I
can't use all I can think of about
solving the the inflation issue is
making fuel cheaper but it's not fuel
it's also food it's also rent a lot of
that stuff is result the reason food's
expensive is because you got to use fuel
to get it from the farm factory but that
also doesn't doesn't include human
expectation inflation is also High
because people demand clean running
water air conditioning Refrigeration hot
showers lot that stuff comes from
combustion which is carbon based it's
your answer graphine it's your answer
everything it's Hy but but it's it's
it's an overly simplistic answer it's
not completely wrong energy plays a huge
role in inflation fuel particularly but
the issue is if people did not want
these things they would work for Less
inflation is a huge component of
inflation is the demands of the people
and what they're willing to work for and
there are a lot of Millennials there's a
poll that came out Millennials are
broken people the Millennials said they
would only be they would be happy with
500,000 a year every other generation
they said every sacrifice yeah every
other generation said 120 yeah of course
120 and I'm happy melo's like 500 now
what what do you think happens you take
a generation of people who want 500
Grand and you say hey we want to pay you
we'll pay you $15 an hour to work at
Starbucks they go no I want 500 Grand
you're like okay well we need to hire
people and they're demanding massive
salaries because they want to be able to
buy a bunch of stuff the average person
doesn't want they make this argument
poverty shouldn't exist abolish poverty
these other arguments like poverty today
is wealth 400 years ago yes there will
always be poverty 100 years ago
seriously because poverty is relative
yes so it's not so simple inflation is
not just a component of the cost of fuel
it's demands of the population and what
they're willing to work for inflation
and the cost of goods is a component of
how much energy a person will spend for
one hour in exchange for how much energy
do they get back and everybody wants
more energy back than they put out
Millennials want five to 10 times the
energy they put out back and so it's not
so simple to just say cheaper energy
solves the problem because when you
let's say we do have an energy
Revolution energy becomes 10% cheaper
you know what happens who's the who's
the guy who did that formulation for the
cost of gas based on uh the use of gas
based on the cost of gas he basically is
early 1900s found that when gas is
cheaper people spend the same amount of
money on gas they just drive more when
you make gas expensive they just drive
less and the price and and and they
spend a flat cost yes that if someone
has 50 bucks left over they'll be like
I'll just drive around for no reason I
wouldn't consider 10% a revolution if if
you could drop the cost of fuel by like
99% that would be a revolution and what
we end up seeing is people will just
drive more maybe or they'll be get so
much time or or they'll just use more
gas cons consuming Vehicles like the
rocket this is ex no but this is exactly
what they saw when gas got cheaper
people bought gas guzzlers because gas
is cheap now right it did not it does
not so you you you look at this issue
and you're like a single individual can
make the decision that because gas is
cheaper I'll live frugally and I'll save
10 bucks and buy more food not what
happens on the macro level people will
drive more they'll buy gas guzzlers and
the amount they spend on travel Remains
the Same people us used to not be able
to afford meat in this country right it
used to be a big thing now everyone even
though the price have gone up have can
can afford me it's not they eating less
meat mhm they just buy more yeah
yeah yeah the cost of food gets cheaper
people don't don't save money on food
now they just eat until they're dead I
think that's why the not depopulation
but degrowth uh this that they people
want the human race to be expanding
slower it's like you might call it
conspiracy I don't know but that's I
think that's why it is explicit because
humans unfettered will just expand and
grow and consume well any animal but
that's not the problem it is absolutely
amazing looking at the International
Space Station I believe the cost of it
was $3 billion and all of the Power of
human Minds all across the planet came
together to develop technology and the
capability to send people into space to
live up there for months on end that is
human Minds coming together more people
means we'll just start colonizing off
the planet we'll figure these things out
the problem is culture and so degrowth
is not the answer they're saying you
know live in the pot eat the bugs well
that's that's an argument the solution
actually is cultural change people need
to be they need they need to eat less
food they need to recognize food is
cheap now don't buy 10 times of it they
need to recognize Community is important
you need to have uh creativity culture
and development amen the problem is
while we have a ton of really amazing
people working really hard to develop
technology so we can go outer space we
have too many people who H what what
what is a uh youall Harari call them
useless eaters and so the solution in my
view to the quote unquote useless eater
is wow look at all these people that
could put their potential to the
advancement of human civilization that
haven't been a properly appropriated and
what do they say put them in pods give
them the bugs and let them play video
games until they no longer exist and
don't have kids Harvest their body heat
for electricity cuz that's not a real
thing though that's you can Harvest piso
electricity like heat friction from
electricity the energy lost from that is
a mat The Matrix did that and the only
reason they came with that concept was
because people would understand the
concept of a neural net so you know har
energy from human body is ridiculous did
The Matrix just do that cuz they had to
have a reason why they didn't just kill
all the people no it was uh uh the
original idea in The Matrix was that
first humans chose the Matrix oh that
makes more sense okay and and that is
Canon and that the the reason the robots
needed them was for a neural network to
basically create a massive okay that
makes sense to their brains are used to
compute The Matrix the argument that
more people means more expansion isn't
it's not doesn't track because like a
deer population if it expands too
rapidly it'll eat all the food and then
it'll starve and have a mass starvation
de deer don't inv invent spaceships
though yes but most humans don't either
it's a very very small percentage of
humans that have that kind of mine
capacity that's not true at all well
because the Cobalt we use for our
technology is not mined by rocket
scientists slaves yeah but the people
that build the Rockets or someone else
so we don't like the conditions in the
Cobalt mines but we're not going to send
Einstein to a Cobalt mine you you the
the what what we should have is a
forested gump like person who can't
build a rocket but dude can run really
really fast you can run best sure
undoubtedly yes there there is a role
for everyone on God's green earth the
problem is oh no no no you're I
completely disagree you don't think so
no most people are as irrelevant as a
butterfly and they have as much impact
on on and they can't they can't break
rocks for us sure but but I I but we are
at a point where chat GPT is a better
conversationalist than the average human
being but I don't care about
conversation I care about who's going to
pick up the Cobalt for our smartphones I
think much of these things like Co like
like can be done by robots or machines I
that's I do not believe that's correct
right now perhaps in the future sure I
don't think it's I don't think it's
going be far in the future it's just
it's just not it's just not um
economically Fe Fair Point perhaps the
big concern of the Bill Gates types is
that once we come to a point where uh
trivial and menial labor is done by
machines you will only require higher
thinking human beings in which case the
quote unquote useless leader useless
eaters become a very serious liability
we're at a point where I would much
rather and most other people would
rather interact with the touchcreen than
with cas year at a fast food place
because the odds of me getting my order
correct are much higher and it's going
to be more faster and more efficient
that's a problem I I I agree and
disagree uh I think you you are correct
it will likely be higher but I also
think the issue is not just the cashier
but the guy making the food correct so
until we eliminate that role but that's
also happened now they have the maches
yes they have they have fully automated
McDonald I think it's McDonald's I could
be wrong but there was a video I saw
where you go to a Kias in order and then
behind the counter you actually watch
the robot arm grab the burger yeah put
it on the grill take it out flips puts
it on the bun then the thing drops all
the ingredients folds like automated
Taco Bell in somewhere in the midwest
it's like a drive-thru completely there
are no humans who work there find so I
think I'm pretty sure it may have been
you've all know Harari who said this or
someone else but the idea that they have
is when the next Industrial Revolution
happens to avoid a lite Riot what you
have to do is before the Revolution
plate the masses by stimulating dopamine
put them in a situation where they can
play video games all day and get free
food they will
eventually just die off and then you we
won't have to worry about violence so
what's interesting is you have that book
right there which I just interviewed
Alex Jones about the great reset and his
entire book is about quotes from these
guys where they're not just it's not
like horror porn they're advocating for
Brave New World like this is what we
want there's no other way around it um
and I don't think that I think this is
actually a real concern because what if
you you are a millennial low IQ low
ambition uh a sense of entitlement what
am I going to what what am I I'm going
to be making C I'm going to be breaking
Cobalt in the minds no I'm not so so
what you do with that where's the
problem what do you do with that person
you give him a video game sure that's
right exactly that's the point and so
where's the problem then are any of us
upset that entitled woke Millennials
will go lock themselves in a pod eating
bugs and playing the Matrix at a certain
point if they're all on welfare it's
going to become costly and someone's
going to be like why are we paying for
all these people in their pods video
games that's when the problem comes in
so they don't run around burning
everything down because they don't want
to break rocks sure but the point is
then they start reproducing and they
start voting all sorts of other things
start happening which is why they're
also sterilizing themselves and aborting
their children sure but I don't think
they're Al they're sterilizing
themselves means thinking ahead so a lot
of them are not going to be thinking
ahead because they'll be operating on a
Pleasure Principle have you seen the
there's there's a article that was being
shared it said study finds uh single uh
women are H in their 40 or was like Sing
Sing women are happier when they're
single and
childless that's that I think that's
what it was and it showed like a clip
from the show Girls and then my response
was yeah until they're 35 right yeah but
for real and so what's happening is you
have this corporate press apparatus
telling all these young women not to
have families and they buy into it a but
the thing is this isn't even some
hypothetical sci-fi thing this is
literally like 20
2019 happening for years Al Alex Jones
described it as they tell you they are
setting bear traps and if you are too
stupid to avoid them it's your own fault
I don't think it's too stupid it's too
trusting and we're taught since we're
kids to trust these people so it's very
hard to be like holy crap I've been lied
to since kindergarten we definitely here
what I'm going to do that's tough I mean
we got I want to talk more about this
but we'll go into a dark territory so
save for the members only and we'll jump
to a a more um irreverent sort of
subject but something a bit uh um to
provide some levity we have this tweet
from the Colorado Republican party that
I saw oh boy okay Democrats love to let
criminals Crim uh criminals loose on the
street this is what happens when you
elect woke crime Huggers to power The
Simpsons prediction certainly stands the
test of time I am in love with this clip
you ready I'll be back you can't keep
the Democrats out of the White House
forever and when they get in I'm back on
the streets with all my criminal
Buddies
[Laughter]
I love that with all my criminal buddies
can I make a point yeah it was Trump uh
who had the Jud the criminal reform and
let out a lot of people yeah but that's
not I'm just I'm just just but but that
we like the criminal reform what we
don't like is when they arrest salon
owners and then literally unleash
violent criminals into the cities what I
don't like is when people who are like
Kyle Rittenhouse and the guy in New York
I don't remember his name jangel Penny
yes who are doing the job the police who
is ostensibly supposed to be doing are
the ones who pay the consequence that
are traumatized for Life Luke Luke uh
has has a video about this from a decade
ago where a guy was stabbing people on
the Metro in New York City and the cops
were like I'm not getting involved and
there was a court ruling that police are
not obligated to save that's the case
yeah yeah and so this guy intervenes and
gets stabbed several times in the head
and stuff and then stops this as soon as
he subdues him then the police come in
but they were like I'm not going
anywhere near that knife what about what
happened in Britain recently with the
you know the pro Palestinian marches and
the guy who Pro who tried to stop them
who was the like a British Patriot he
got arrested of course there's um uh you
say of course but I don't think it's of
I don't think a lot of people realize to
what extent it's screwed up I mean we
talk about it sure sure uh Dan dicks uh
do you know you know Dan no journalist
he was in Canada and there was a protest
he show up to film it they started
screaming and attacking him so the cops
are threaten to arrest him I think he
might have actually I think he had
detained and then removed it's like the
innocent guy who shows up doing nothing
is attacked and and then you defend the
attackers not just innocent heroic yeah
this is this this is what I've warned
about is is is is coming when the guy in
uh Wisconsin had BLM show up to his
house his private residents protesting
and he brandished a shotgun the police
showed up and arrested him and BLM
cheered for it they don't want to
abolish the police they want the police
to just arrest you m yes I mean and that
that's been crystal clear from day
one definitely I mean I think one of the
issues has always been that the
marketing tactic says one thing but the
the demand is something else right they
they just want certain people to be
allowed to do things that they want they
are willing to excuse your violence or
your lawlessness if you support their
idea of who should be forgiven and once
again the first people who are going to
be the victims of violent crime are
going to be the poor yeah like it just
goes back to that again they're the most
likely to be killed raped whatever all
this other stuff and they're the least
likely have access to Legal Services to
have some kind of Retribution or Justice
it's horrifying well and then they're
trapped in communities that have all of
these issues and we never find a way to
solve them because ultimately we're
funding it by saying we don't need to we
don't need to really investigate these
causes we'll just say here's money we'll
fix it also we'll let you out of jail go
back in the community we'll never
address the core issues it's just and it
just me crazy this hand waving from
conservatives like well they shouldn't
vote a Democrat fine I'm stuck in the
projects I hate this like my life is
screwed I go and vote Republican what's
going to change everyone else around me
is voting Democrat what am I supposed to
do this system's been Ed for 100 years
move I guess but I can't afford you know
I'm in the projects I can't afford to
move not everyone who's poor is poor
because of choice that they've made but
this is another important distinction a
person who has a house is not poor
relative to someone 100 or 200 years ago
absolutely and so it's interesting to
see that people are now saying like I
can't move I can't afford to move and
I'm like do you live somewhere yeah I
live in government housing I'm like they
there's this great line in fast fast and
furious 4 where the bad guy says would I
follow this line if I haven't seen the
first three yes okay he said he I'm
paraphrasing but he says if I give them
things they become dependent upon me and
then they serve me and so these people
who are like yeah I know that what's
happening in my city is wrong I know
what they're doing is evil but I can't
move because I'm stuck here and it's
like that was the plan oh yeah you are
dependent on them and now they beat you
and you can't do anything about it
except for cheer for them right there's
article I read a while ago about a study
on universal basic income and they were
trying to find women I think in Jackson
Mississippi to come be a part of this uh
Ubi tests for like a year and when they
were approaching women they were like
well the thing is I don't want to lose
my benefits because once I have them
it's difficult if I lose them it's
difficult to get back on them so it's
better to maintain them for as long as I
can and that's a really interesting
system right because ultimately
theoretically any sort of Social Service
like that would be to help you for a
small amount of time to that get back on
your feet be able to yeah and that's not
the way it it works out and it was more
of a private charity system they would
be much more Hands-On you'd have more
oneon-one relationships or 1 to 10 you
know maybe some kind of classes and they
will be focusing on transitioning people
from poverty into some like there's this
great um charity that pallette worked
for when he was on The Apprentice twice
called Opportunity Village where people
who are like sever who mentally disabled
it's like in Vegas they give them jobs
so like they made Elvis's costumes like
they're not going to be able to build
rocket ships but they can have some
dignity and they mind Cobalt yeah yeah
man unemployment should be you get some
little bit but then if you get a job you
get more and then that lasts for 6
months and then you're only eligible
every 5 years to get that path or
something there should be an incentive
get a job we could also have this off in
schools right like we could have high
schoolers who are all graduating with
the requirement that they have some
level of financial literacy that they
understand the con consequences of
credit card debt of student loans but we
don't do that right and the obvious
example with student loans is that the
government wants you to agree to take
out student loans which are crippling
that at 18 you may not know the
consequences of and that you are
dependent on them you are waiting for
Joe Biden to forgive them and hopefully
he will and maybe if we vote for him
again he'll finally forgive the student
loans that are ruining my life or
transition from college is this liberal
arts idea of this like 1890s creating
the next generation of Elites to have
more of a mentorship apprenti program
instead of four years at Yale I'm
spending four years at some company and
I'm starting from the bottom and I have
a mentor within the company who teaches
me the ropes I I I got an idea abolish
public schooling well I I that's a
little extreme Tim I I'm for it are you
for it are you kidding me that's the
first thing I'd abolish okay then so
we're in agreement number one yes public
schooling is gone uh uh government
schools are literal prisons for children
and the only place many people ever
encounter violence in their you ever see
the story about the uh the kid in Chico
prisons the kid in Chicago who was
locked in a padded room and then he they
wouldn't let him go to the bathroom so
he crapped himself and was
crying the school a school in Chicago
had a padded room to lock kids in I
remember I was audio where he's like
please I'll be good let me out yep you
could hear kid crying some of those are
like daycare like parents that work
single parent yeah so if you abolished
it all those kids would be homeless
essentially or that's why we have a lot
of work to do no fault divorce gone okay
19th Amendment gone well I don't about
17th Amendment for sure that the
senators are elected that's no-brainer
yes I was talking to some Missouri gone
public education gone all that yeah I
was talking to some Missouri State Rep
saying this should be the thing that you
make your bones on you should uh get rid
of no fault divorce in your state
because as soon as one state does it all
the other states will follow I think
this is something culture really wants
to change and we see that the argument
like oh you know people don't believe
abuse or whatever else like those things
are so different in the modern era and
restructuring the family and creating
social support system that begin at home
is really important there was a story
that um no the overturning of row no
fault divorce if you take that away
you're going to be getting a lot more
rape accusations of for innocent men
because why wouldn't women play that
card right that's a cultural problem yes
it is but say l i i i don't like I don't
think say l when like if you're going to
I mean this is a moral hazard that's
right but men who go through women will
commit crimes therefore we should not
fix the system I I don't I I didn't say
I'm just saying if you're going to tear
down a fence you should be aware why it
was put up and what the consequences and
just anticipate them think the fence was
put up because people were concerned
about false R accusations I think the
left is trying to just destroy this
country sure but what I'm saying is I
think the this people in this country
generally are not used to the concept of
trade-offs right and just because
something is a good thing does it mean
like the idea that for example let's
suppose the vaccines were actually
prevented Co and Co was deadly but
you're probably going to get the flu for
two weeks it's a cost but it's a cost
you're willing to pay because the cost
out weighs the theost right so but
people don't think in those terms like
you can't say like this is something you
have to do even though it's going to
hurt a little bit it has to be this
something you has to do and there's
never cost to it called opportunity cost
economics exactly I think the issue for
humans is that they only ever want to
drift towards the path of lease
resistance and so the reason why you
have wokeness today is that uh all that
is required for able to try is that good
men do nothing so when the woke left
starts causing destruction damage pain
and suffering it is easier just to Bow
your head and say Let It Go Let It Go
choose your battles and now here we are
another big problem is when people
become obsessively goal oriented and
it's like I want that goal at any cost
if the goal is to remove the fence what
How is how's that going really what we
should be doing is making a plan as to
how we're going to take that fence down
because there's a lot of ways the fence
could get removed there's a lot of ways
that the Department of Education could
disappear and one of them would be like
the United States disappearing or like a
global language so we got to be real
careful about how we're going to
disassemble this thing if we want to do
it and still maintain semblance of peace
and Order there's a book by Carol
marwitz and Bethany Mandel called um
stolen youth which I just read and you
know we're I think most of it's like you
think that a lot of the stuff that's
going on in school is like right-wing
propaganda and people frothing at the
mouth but the receipts you see and
talking to parents about what's going on
in schools cuz we're not in school so
we're kind of oblivious to it it's all
everything secondhand it is so f up I I
don't even know where to start right and
then the left lies and say it's not
happening and the media covers for them
even though it's like here's the book
here's the receipts Noe information is
good math is good but like a lot of that
stuff it was real America Centric my
history lessons Columbus sailed the
ocean blue and discovered America like I
don't think you we need to teach our
kids that in the future I'm open to like
living on a farm in some foreign country
and just teaching the kid how to farm
and eat fruit and like identify plants
and like the real important stuff I math
is good too I don't know if I'm tottally
responding what you're saying but I
disagree I think having a sense of
patriotism is good and I think it is a
way to build Common Ground between
people who come from different
socioeconomic backgrounds I think if we
just made it as like well America's just
whatever it will actually further
stratify uh the cultural enclaves that
we have here are things we aren't taught
in schools how to fill out an income tax
form uh how to work the legal system
works logical fallacies if there was
just a course in I I learned in Junior
High how to calculate the due point in
Brooklyn and how to calculate when the
water's saturated in the earth when
there's too much rain I was not taught
to calculate interest rates or I learned
about photosynthesis yeah helps me out a
lot mitochondria is the PowerHouse of
the cell that was an important one yeah
yeah so it's crazy what the priorities
are we could say this is like a
financial literacy you have to be able
to be able to take care of yourself you
have to be able to understand how to
read your lease or you know all these
basic things when I was when I was a kid
they made us watch a cartoon where Adam
was writing a
brontosaurus Adam who Adam oh Adam and
Eve who do you think he's talking about
he was riding a brontosaurus what what
did you go to public school uh it was
this was Private Catholic School the
issue was uh and then they were
basically like the reason the dinosaurs
died was because they couldn't fit on
the ark they're too big yeah the
propagandas but there but there were
small dinosaurs well you know the point
is they didn't want to leave their
friends behind that doesn't make sense
but those the big ones small ones they
didn't want to let them starve dinosaurs
surviv rived they're in my backyard
there's a bunch of them they're
screaming all day yes the chickens yeah
it is hilarious really ridiculous
question ask I come on this is your
best ranked we'll save it for the MERS
on the after show we're going to go to
Super Chat fit but maybe I'll do it all
right if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends head over to Tim cast.com click
join us become a member cuz the M
members only uncensored show is going to
be awesome and we are going to talk
about the Rosanne thing in the back a
big thing apparently Michael was like no
it's a big deal everyone's going to be
really excited to hear about Roseanne so
definitely go to
timcast.net later still get that
discount code so do it now because uh
tomorrow is the last day tomorrow is the
last day we have for uh sales tracking
we're trying to get as many sales as
possible the best song ever.com we uh
need your support and I'm really excited
because it'll mean that Jeremy boring
Michael nolles Tim pool Carter Banks we
will all be on the Billboard charts I
think I think we're there in some
fashion probably at a low ranking right
now we need to sell I don't think we're
definitely not going to hit it if we
sold like 50,000 we'd be hot 100 and
then you're then you're on the list you
know how close you are we're we're not
going to hit it we're like 25% maybe if
everybody listening right now went to
the best song ever.com and downloaded it
then together again would would very
likely be a Hot 100 song and it would be
the funniest thing ever because then the
entertainment media would have to what
right about why we were able to do this
how we were able to do it they say you
hacked the system and I and I and I want
them to yeah you're right because if
encouraging your fans to buy a song is
hacking the system what does that say
about them because the reality of the
music industry is it's fake all of it is
fake 100% for decades the way it works
is there's deals upon deals one company
has a deal with another company you want
your song in rotation you know you know
this is this is what really is is so
irksome it's it's not just that they
they told you know the story they told
Jeremy boring he offered him 150 Grand
to play one song one time and they told
him no and likely for political reasons
sure certainly for political reasons
when we published our first song and it
was not even political we got an email
back from one uh entertainment
publication saying go yourselves in
those words in those words and so that
that I get welcome to the world also
there's issues with there like oh no the
numbers aren't being tracked properly I
think we're looking at something like
2,000 or like whoopsy daisies but the
issue that really bugs me is when you
see these songs charting you're like
who's this guy we look at the chart
we're like what is this band I've never
even heard of it because what they'll do
is the label will go to a streaming
platform and they'll say do you want
insert celebrity artist then you've got
to guarantee us that you're going to put
this guy on rotation and we want this
song played every 16 times which
guarantees them x million hits which
guarantees them charting on Billboard
and all of these things and so when
we're talking to various people in the
in in the industry and we're like What
do we what do we have to do to hit these
these you know these same metrics like
how do how do we get a we have a new
song it's in this genre it's in this
they'll never let you in here's here's
the other thing I know a lot about this
from my genre which is publishing the
New York Times best Star list which is
by all accounts the most cred the most
respected and desirable list to get on
it has very little sales it's all
editori they don't even tell you what
the rankings are it if you have a lot of
sales they can just flat out ignore you
regnery which is a publishing house for
conservatives they're not even they
don't even submit to the New York Times
list anymore because they said it was so
fake which is kind of frustrating for
those reary authors who sell a lot of
books but they literally are explicit
about like even people who work at the
New York Times don't know how they make
up this rankings so here's what I'm
hoping I'm hoping that we can we'll
Force our way in yes and look it really
just comes down to this first and
foremost C brw coffee we're on track for
over a million dollars in our first year
when we were doing our filing we had
this like this third party contractor
like helping us out and they were like
when did you start the business and we
were like April and they went what like
they were shocked to hear how well it
was doing so thank you everybody
supporting caspr and uh the coffee
Shop's currently underway the furniture
and tables and everything for the club
is is happening so that should be
opening hopefully in the next couple of
months and there will be a physical
location to hang out I know it's taking
too long to get the coffee shop up but
it's because of regulations and and
building code and stuff like that but uh
we're also just trying to we want to
make music we want to make music we want
to sell it so we're hoping people buy it
you know when you know you've made it
when you have the Articles talking about
how much your music sucks cuz first they
ignore you then they have to laugh at
you and denigrate you yeah want I feel
you forced uh together again already now
it's been forced now it's just riding
like it's hot in Toronto it's I heard
it's hot in Asia somewhere trending in
Toronto and Hong Kong I think it made it
like now it's good just to rest on
it Japanese Tik Tok we we know the sales
numbers and they're good but they're
nowhere near where we would need them to
be and so that's fine that's fine I'm
not like pumping money into promotion
now we we're we're spending a lot on
marketing and it is what it is we we've
sold what we could sell we have today
and tomorrow tomorrow's the last day so
like I said if everybody listening right
now went to the best song ever.com and
bought the song We would absolutely hit
Hot 100 when we're finally able to do
that is when they're going to drop a
load in their pants actually I think
it's this is industry only it's when it
gets into a movie like a really pop
which it could do just listen man if it
into a big popular movie then it's like
outside of your hands cuz it's the kind
of song where people are going to pick
it up and play it locally we we have
been dealing with this for two years now
uh our first song was published in 2020
we didn't we we were I was I was like I
don't even know how to make it work it
got millions of hits people know the
song will of the people it did really
really well we get ripped off we get
spat on you don't just get in a movie
yeah aord political it's all politics
there's no circumstance where our songs
land in movies it's noten you say that
out loud sure sure it's a fact you want
that to not happen go for it I mean it
could definitely land in a movie it's an
awesome song That's not how it works
that's not how it works you're wrong I'm
not saying it's going to be in
Paramount's next feature but it could in
four years after we win the culture War
perhaps yes the way it works is a guy in
Hollywood goes to his friend across the
street and says what song do you want
placed in the movie end of story it
could be in Daily wire's next big thing
no but hold on can I say one thing all
seriously what how it works is the CIA
director cast CIA actors and actresses
and has a CA production assistant and
has CA or Affiliated musicians to do the
soundtrack these big agencies work that
way so if Tim's not CAA or gers or any
of these other agencies he it doesn't
have to be Radioactive in terms of
politics like it's just not enough and
so this is my point yes you're right it
could get in the daily wire and what
would the daily wire do for us are they
going to get us on CA UTA or any of
these big networks no it could as the
daily wire is doing now help Drive sales
which is why we teamed up with them both
of both Jeremy boring Michael nolles me
Carter banks are all like we have been
pushing back on woke Industries and
their control of these systems so the
only thing they cannot prevent is if we
sell enough we hit Hot 100 and then the
entertainment media is going to be
dropping a load in their pants being
like they are invading our spaces and we
can't stop them and the other thing is
it's not just specifically woke it's
also ingroup and outgroup right it's
just simply that like we all we're all
friends in La like we work together
who's this guy from Shelby it's just not
happening we don't want someone to take
our power from us so we've built walls
around the industry that you have to
come to us and pay your dues you got to
join our unions you got to file your
paperwork with us and we say if your
music is good or not there's a there's
there's a song I Really yes there a song
I really really like and it was on my
rotation in my playlist when I'm skating
and I looked up the song it had 1500
views on YouTube that was it there were
articles written about this song and I
was like that is what they do they
decide that some guy who produced a song
in his garage and he did and it's a good
song they decided we're going to make
this song and you know what else they do
they own it so when someone like us says
we're going to make our own music they
say we don't own it so you're not
welcome here right when when when when
our publicist said here's a new song we
literally got back in email saying go f
yourselves and so I'm just like but that
was for me to be fair yeah War you just
get so aggressive about music it's Dr
Pepper zero you ask yourself why it is
that like when you when you open Pandora
Spotify or whatever and you open a
playlist there's music on it who chooses
that can I can I you can you can be
friends with some of these guys like
let's say you're a musician and you know
a guy who works at this place you might
find your song in rotation
congratulations I am such a hipster that
when I was on Rogan I think the time
before last I wore a t-shirt from an a
tweet pop band that I'm like okay I'm
going to get all these accolades because
not one person knew the band like not
one person in the comments anywhere was
like oh he likes that band so we're
going to read some Super Chat we're
going to read super chats here let's do
it Clint Torres hits the first Super
Chat again with howdy people and dzala
sorry he says first with a you know oh
fingers no you are not first sorry
Robert suben boach says first please
unblock me
Michael I don't even know I don't know
who you are that seems like it's not
true I feel like there's decep I block
people on the regular Cil loocks
production says while the Colorado
ruling on removing Trump from the ballot
has a stay until January 4th there was
also a clause that states if it is
challenged to the US Supreme Court that
stay becomes indefinite meaning this is
a BS ruling it's not a BS ruling it's a
testing of the waters maybe it's legally
BS but it's politically testing the
waters yeah 52 movies a year says
Michael when will you be paying rosan
her 1K up up up we will talk about this
in the members only show because Michael
has like a huge thing about it I had
I've had a 20-minute imaginary argument
with you guys okay he's he's he's mapped
out the entire conversation get the bit
yeah and he's and he's he's bested us
before we even realize it not saying I
won the imaginary argument I'm just
saying I had it you come prepared you
your documents all right yes UNCA gug
says how's bcus doing well um he's very
uh chill yeah he's uh he's walking
around he's doing his thing uh I am kind
of worried though he's he's Rel he's
relatively low energy his energy has
been going down he's made it a year
longer than we thought it was that he
thought he we thought he would and uh
the scary thing to me was that he's
trying to hide a lot that's bad yes an
indication that he feels sick yeah you
know depends on his mood a lot of times
cats are really in tune with how you
feel so if there's stress in the
environment they'll go away from it and
if you're really in a good mood they'll
come join you my cat never absolutely
and right end only time hit from me it
was really sad bcus giving into the left
inan yeah cats go and hide because when
they're sick they they try to protect
themselves from predators by hiding
intention can make you sick yeah I don't
think Mr Bokus can psychically sense our
emotions I think he is sick because his
kidneys are failing and so he is hiding
because it's an instinct cats have to
hide from predators when they're weak
and for this the more he tries to hide
the more worried I become um if it was
just that some people here are stressed
out I actually wouldn't feel bad at all
but I choose not to live in those worlds
I choose to live in the world of
sometimes it's the self it's like a self
uh perpetuating cycle where cat cat
looks ill and then you become nervous
and sad and then the cat becomes more
ill and then you become more sad but if
you can stay positive he comes back out
and he gets very active druish AF says I
cannot use PayPal so I can't buy the
song as uh uh best song ever as your
link to receive the Casper discount any
alternatives for longtime timcast
members I think that was basically the
only way we could we could actually make
that work you can buy the song on iTunes
and uh we we were number one on iTunes
in the first day which is awesome but we
are not pushing iTunes sales because we
we have this discount code sure but uh
iTunes and uh Amazon if you go to the
bestsong ever.com there's Amazon as well
and and I know nobody likes these things
but look we're we're just trying to
storm the gates it it is what it is and
uh yeah unfortunately that was the best
way we could do it the the the sale for
a lot of people have pointed this out if
you want to buy the song and get the
discount code it the default is H is
Paypal but I think you just enter you
don't need an account or anything you
use your credit card and it processes by
PayPal and one thing I also want to
point out because M being Mr Whitefield
here what you another one of course yeah
um I just have like a vending machine
under on the desk I think for people who
think think America's doomed or the West
is doomed first of all I always say we
don't need a majority we just need an
alternative yeah but there are so many
people especially young people who are
champing at the bit to be able to
support creators that they like and and
are just they're like how can I support
you give me like product to buy I want
to wear the shirts I want to buy your
music so if you do have that number and
I think the number is very clearly
increasing that also bodess very well
for the future of our culture you know I
don't think the United States is doomed
but like Nazi Germany Germany wasn't
doomed because of what happened in the
30s it just changed and that's where I
feel like the United States is headed
well I mean Germany was invaded split in
half so I don't I think and leveled I
mean they bombed to Oblivion we have we
got a good one here from n M8 he says
maybe the Civil War statues are being
removed to make room for the upcoming
Civil War statues
foreshadowing yikes that's a good one
yeah I like that one oh
boy Bas Jew says Dear Tim please find a
way to bring the Insane Clown onto the
culture War woo woo uh I think we did
talk about booking them one at one point
yeah violent violent Jay's autobiography
is very good yeah what's their politics
like are they they're they're lefties um
they're they're very here I this is a
red pill moment for me I I remember like
this must been 10 15 years ago I had one
of their albums friend gave it to me and
it's actually there's like what there's
a song called still stabbing because
like it starts with I still have this
stabbing problem it's a sequel to the
song stabbing and I had a job interview
and the guy interviewing me was like 27
I was just me I maybe it was job
interview it was like my uh I was doing
temping work and I talking about this
band and he sings about throwing the hea
the record label out the window and he
rides on the bicycle seat without the
seat because he killed the post worker
and he goes yeah man some people are so
crazy and I'm like they call themselves
clowns they wear clown makeup and what
how many cues do you need that this is a
joke I like that the FBI classifies them
as a sort of a terrorist organization
The Jug the The Jug get a bad rap icps
some good music this great culture where
I'm totally this is what I spent the
beginning of 2020 pandemic researching
and on my Facebook there's a picture of
me I got the fa I did the face pain as
violent Jay once so I would love to meet
violent Jay or Shaggy all right hunter
killer says with this ruling they are
getting dangerously close to a
contingent election happening yeah I
think there uh that's another
possibility we may see Trump V DeSantis
RFK Biden in 2024 if the if the GOP is
split they pull they pull Trump off the
ballot Dan santis win wins Donald Trump
runs as an independent RFK independent
then it's Democrat Republican
independent independent Donald Trump of
course wins the plurality which gives
him the well the plurality numbers but
not the Electoral College which results
in a contingent election where state
delegations will then have to choose
Donald Trump then wins the left then
says Trump not only didn't win he only
got 27% of the vote or you know 31%
didn't even win the electoral college
and his cronies appointed him and
they'll use it as justification for
their extreme violence
it's not impossible I I think it's very
unlikely agreed yeah okay yeah all right
Marian Holzman says all right I bought
the song everybody come on now 69 cents
is very reasonable support our culture
War I'll say this uh we put out the song
bright eyes and we did nothing to
promote it uh it was fun to make we made
a music video for it we had a good time
uh it is what it is I also recognize
it's not just about hey we made a song
quick everybody you have to buy it it's
we need like 5,000 songs we need a
massive Library what what we can't do is
make movies we're not movie people but
uh I grew up playing music Ian plays
music Carter Banks is an amazing
producer and the quality of the music
videos we've produced has actually got a
lot of Industry guys really excited
sorry I don't want toite you no no no no
no yeah I was going to make a big
announcement today but uh it was too
close to the holidays but my next
project is I wrote a screenplay about
this band from the 80s that never made
it it's a real band and through the
keyboard player I met Harvey pear her
AOG graphic novel on me called Egon
hubis so I realized I had this script in
my desk since 2004
I should make a graphic novel of it and
it's the real story of this band and I'm
like I was going to start my Indiegogo
but I'm going to do it when I was going
to launch on the show see if we can fund
it live but I'll come back when I'm
ready to do it with do that we're we're
going to have a a completed album I
think around like maybe February or
March I think March and so that means
there's probably going to be like three
or four songs that we never do big
releases for like every song we've put
out has been a video and a promotion
because we're like we're going to come
in with a bang but we we really are just
coming to the point where we're
negotiating with some bands on signing
some bands we need some more artists
ideally we just get to the point where
we spend a million bucks get like 500
songs from a bunch of different artists
out and we just we want to funnel money
into creative people it's not just about
the music that I or Carter is making uh
we're just not at this point yet because
we're small it's like Carter is the one
guy who's running all this stuff ideally
within the next year we have two or
three more bands some producers and
we're putting out like two or three
songs a month from different artists and
so that's what we're going that's where
we're going that's the plan this this
one that we're releasing now was kind of
like I called Jeremy boring and I was
like I got this idea and I explained to
him what we wanted to do and he laughed
his ass off and was like let's roll baby
he told the story about he offered a
hundred times the market rate to play a
song $150,000 and they told him no and
he was like I we know why yeah they're
they're they're keep they're they're
they're gatekeeping and it's not
irrational on their part because if they
if they get the foot in the door then
it's all over yep it's crazy so he made
a fake song mocking them called together
again
and then I said let's make a modern
version of this and and put it out there
and just promote it like crazy and then
get it on Billboard and then keep
mocking them yes telling they can't keep
us out we're we're banging on the door
we're coming in all right let's we'll
grab some more Super chats the best song
ever.com all right where we at uh bikin
153 says I think the reason Colorado is
pushing so hard to get Trump off the
ballot is because sb1
9042 it was passed in 2019 and says that
Colorado's electoral votes go to the
winner of the national popular vote
instead of who Colorado votes for
perhaps but the funny thing about that
is that uh Michael made a good point
about it the point I made in the past
was it opens the door to California
going Republican California is two to1
Democrat but they're part of this
National vote Coalition meaning that if
a republican does win the popular vote
California votes Republican which would
never happen outside of this stupid plan
they have but you made a better Point uh
my friend made a documentary about the
Electoral College and I'm blanking on
the name I feel really bad but he one of
the points he made in the movie is if
you have abolished electoral college and
you just have the popular vote it makes
it a lot easier and encourages a white
nationalist candidate because all you
have to do is Advocate to whites which
are the biggest group by population in
this country by far and you get enough
of them you have the election you why
why pitch toward a group which is 2% or
133% of the population when you could
pitch to a group that's 50% of
population and just with their numbers
alone a few from the others you're going
to have everything you take it's very
dangerous uh um uh strategy for on the
part of the
left let's read some more Paul tascal
says I lost faith in our justice system
in 2016 when Obama pardoned the Iranian
bomb maker it made me sad what Colorado
did to Trump yesterday makes me scared
well hold on I got inter I this drives
me crazy because people think history
started five minutes ago Bill Clinton
par pardoned terrorists who bombed
Congress FAL the faln I think they were
called I don't remember what it was but
there were there were uh I think Puerto
Rican separatists they bombed Congress
and Clinton part can you please look
this up Ian yeah so the talk about the
Insurrection like he let them free and
they they were unrepentant they weren't
like I we promise we'll never do it
again yeah read this out out please I
got a there's a lot of data this is
actually from congress.gov you going to
say it no I was going to say do you want
to collect the yeah I'll take a look and
then I'll let me read this uh toram says
if civil war broke out substations would
get hit everywhere within a month the
grid would never come up feds and
liberals and cities would lose to people
capable of self-governance and survival
within 6 months when their oil ran out
with zero infrastructure I think more
importantly if there was an actual Civil
War you would see attacks on
infrastructure instantly industrial
control control systems are very
vulnerable New York City would become
hell yeah but you'd also very quickly
see globalist backup so Europe would be
coming in China would be coming in it's
we're not the US doesn't exist as a like
ar City in a bubble space I still don't
think New York can maintain a I'm not
arguing with you I'm just saying it
wouldn't be this simple like no no for
sure what I'm saying oh yeah right
British trade routes would be pumping
New York New York would be hell more so
the the power would be would be they
they'd be fighting to keep the power on
that means there's going to be water
issues people without water are going to
it's it's I I don't think they can say
sa yor look at the narrative then
because look what they're doing to these
poor New Yorkers this is this you know
the the shiny matter it'll matter to
some people it'll matter to Karen yeah
but when we're in a civil war we're at
the the Civil War is the point of
brother against
brother they could say whatever they
want in the radio and someone's going to
be like you're you're terrorist
pedophiles I don't care right but
there's other people who would be like
no they're the terrorist pedophiles of
course people in New York are going to
be like look what they're doing to us
exct and they'll be angry about it and
that F Civil War but New York is going
to be a bunch of people eating each
other and I'm I'm not joking I mean they
will literally start consuming human
bodies you have the data oh yeah this is
the uh followup on the Clinton pardon
faln commutation 1999 it was Clinton's
commuted the sentences of 16 members of
this faln a Puerto Rican paramilitary
organization that set up 120 bombs in
the United States mostly in New York
City and
Chicago I I could go on and on about
this I'm going to read this I'm not sure
what he's saying bomb terrorists this is
99 commuted excuse me terrorist digital
DNA says Michael malice if you can't see
how ELO's abuse the power of the system
you have no reason to talk what a foul
opinion your entire argument for
anything else falls apart Leos are The
Gatekeepers to how common folk move wake
up buddy what are Leos cops Law
Enforcement Officers yeah I I I I'm
you're an anarchist who's he talking to
I don't understand I I am I I want to
hear your honest opinion I was having
this conversation with right in mine am
am I incorrect that I am probably by the
the biggest person by far who's gotten
right of Center people red pilled on the
police yeah probably I can't think of
who else would be yeah I feel like a
general opinion of the right is we like
our police officers but too many police
in big cities are completely corrupt and
appointed by democrats which exposes the
the vulnerabilities of the Poli but I
think also conserves now realizing who's
going to come for your guns it's not
going to be Pelosi whereas 10 years ago
strictly Thin Blue Line it's either thus
Oro the riers and I was like wait a
minute they're on the side the Riders
but I mean you even look at uh when we
were talking with Tucker and Charlie
Kirk they they Now understand Occupy
Wall Street a lot better sure these
conversations have opened up and we all
agree occupy was taken over by woke
Psychopaths I love someone having to
tell me how bad the police are and and
that they're basically do what the
government tells them this is
fascinating stuff it's kind of worrying
that they think less of the police than
you or maybe I'm getting trolled in
which case Well Done Right tway Willie
says I also heard Don Jr defend anheiser
Bush on your show maybe him and Dana
know better than us maybe there's
something there it's because anheiser
Bush gives a ton of money to Republicans
a lot and so do they give money to
Democrats as well they often play that
game where they play I I think they give
a substantially large amount of m a
larger amount of money to Republicans
like a lot and so look it really just
comes down to
this the idea that when it comes to Bud
Light we just stop where we are and say
yay boycott it's it's like you you you
won a battlefield and then all your
troops laid down their weapons sat down
and started cooking a roast and it's
like guys we're still at War here
someone's got to be preparing for what
our next move is where are we going what
are we doing and everyone's just like no
no we stay here and I'm like no one
forgave Paul Adine that's true I had
Kurt mear on my show who's a great
comedian I don't know if you guys ever
had on he's I would highly recommend him
and he goes I did the homework this old
like fat Southern lady was robbed at
gunpoint in a bank and that's the only
she had to be traumatized using racial
slur and Kurt this Kurt's line he goes
they should build a statue to Pauline
and have the the plaque say she only
said it once like she's the most but
that's the thing she's still a person
ngada my my my my point on Bud Light
is if conservatives position is there is
no Redemption ever for any company that
crosses them that is exactly the meme of
the left pushing the guy to the right
and then arguing that he's joined ranks
with the right there's Redemption when
there's uh um uh I but but look look I
don't care about Redemption I care about
occupation that's fair but the point is
you I agree there's a rule for
Redemption but the Redemption has to be
we learn from our mistakes and we won't
do it again I think people can be
redeemed but corporations are just shut
them down a corporate apology matters in
the culture war in that it resonates
culturally yes and so if if the if the
argument from people right now is and it
is strongly even in the chat they're
like no no we must do nothing we're
stopping where we are I'm like you need
to take everything Sean Strickland has
said and start cheering for that and Bud
Light as a means to force Bud Light to
issue a statement instead all makes much
more sense to me yes yeah I'm like doing
nothing everyone's like the boycott
stays my position on on Kid Rock Dana
White Joe Rogan is Major cultural forces
have argued for we've we've won and I'm
like okay that means the the the the
Victory and gain here is minimal but at
the very least you send a message to
Corporate America if you cross us we
destroy you but if you side with us we
will make you wealthy yeah you punish
the bad behavior and you reward good
behavior I don't think you need to
reward good behavior I think it's more
of a March through the institution where
if they mess with you you wound them and
then you continue your March and if
another Corporation does it again march
to institutions is gr's idea and the
idea is you seize institutions one by
one and no one's doing any of that no
one's doing any of that are no no I'm
saying right now on the right they're
like we've won because we don't buy Bud
Light okay come April Bud Light will put
$100 million into w
they're going to say the right has
abandoned us and there's no there's no
recovery our only growth opportunity
while minimal will be woke causes double
down it's it'll biate Y and and I'm like
this is why there has to be a move made
now or the other option is to just say
you won Kid Rock says we win Joe Rogan
says we win don't you forget it that's
all you can do because I don't
understand why Kid Rock and Joe Rogan
would want to drink Bud Light maybe I'm
too much of a bougie makes me wonder
like do they make ad money off of it
like they at a certain point did they
have Joe's not like that Joe's not not
it is really it is really it is really
simple Bud Light sponsored Dylan Mulaney
and it pissed everyone off and Kid Rock
said that was bad budik gives UFC $100
million and says oh okay UFC is way more
based got way more people who are pro
Trump trump walks into UFC to Fanfare I
think we got this one but people are
like not good enough if people morals
money were screwed and and they were mad
at money in the first place they were
mad that money went to Dylan M and
they're not satisfied that money coming
coming in this well no it's gender
ideology stuff that was the principal
reason that they were selling of course
and I agree with that and so the issue
is sending money to the UFC is a
structural Victory it's not the greatest
culture War Victory it's not exactly
what you want but you've if if you're
not satisfied with it you cannot do
nothing and the idea that all anyone has
to do right now is just not buy budlight
is wrong and so my argument has been
everyone please Shan Strickland said
January 6 was the most patriotic thing
this country has done in a long time
everyone should take that tweet quote
tweet it with a picture of them holding
up budlight saying thanks budlight for
paying for this message thank you for
sponsoring this and fueling patriotism
the other thing I I'm wondering about I
could be wrong it seems to me remember
like not that long ago Linda sarur was
everywhere yeah that as soon as there's
a push back against a massive Muslim
immigration you can't even find this
this bee on the side of a mil carton is
D malany now kind of become radioactive
and has been vanished or no let's let's
do this we'll go to the memb Z we'll
talk about that
I can tell you a lot about that uh if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast cuz we got some
more spicy things to talk about with
Michael Roseanne the election of course
um we'll talk about uh dlan mvan and
things like that over at Tim cast.com in
about a minute head over to the bestsong
ever.com if everybody listening right
now just spent that 69 cents you would
save a crap ton of money on cast brew
coffee and you would help us and the
guys with the daily wire push back on
woke Industries and support support our
endeavors in creating new cultural
machines we're going to build our own
music industry and it starts with a
snowball rolling down a hill we could
use your support you can follow the show
at timcast IRL follow everywh we got
Clips on Instagram you can follow me
personally at timcast Michael do you
want to shout anything out uh you can
follow me on Twitter Michael malis
YouTube Michael mes official and for
those of you guys who are Christmas
orphans we'll be doing a Christmas live
stream from Austin the Austin crew it's
going to be me uh the side surfice to do
those realistic cakes Ty Rivera uh and a
few leex Freedman supposedly at a few
other people so I think it's really
important like you were saying earlier
Tim that we create spaces for people to
be able to feel like they're part of a
community and that's one of the things
I'm so excited about being in Austin
being able to be a part of that so and
I'm going to have big news uh my episode
Jordan peerson again drops tomorrow on
his podcast and I'll launch that inogo
maybe I'll come back on here and launch
it here for super good fun it live
sounds cool I love your Christmas live
stream that's so it's so festive I feel
like people don't realize you have to
make Christmas fun uh I'll make it I'll
just say one more thing about the
Christmas thing so Natalie um uh e nebit
is my favorite author she's a British
children's author so from the late 1800s
early 1900s I read all her books every
time there's a weird dish mentioned I
had a list so we'll be cooking a bunch
of those weird British dishes weird
British food for Christmas it's the best
way to celebrate uh I'm Hannah cler
I'm a writer for cnr.com also known as
scanner news if you want to follow their
work you can still follow timcast newws
on Instagram and Twitter if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Twitter at
hana. B and I'm on Instagram at h no
hold on that's backwards I'm on Twitter
at hcbo and I'm on Instagram at handler.
be guys thank you so much follow me
everywhere at Ian Crossland and check
out my interviews daily well some days I
interviewed uh Ben Stewart today we had
a great talk about a little bit we got
into techn humanism it was pretty
awesome so check it out and I'll see you
later and I'm surge.com uh yeah great to
have you back Michael as always uh
excited for this after show it's going
to be fun so let's get to it all right
we'll see you all over at timcast.net